What the fuck ist...
Oh.
So.
Irgendwie habe ich mich noch...
Halt ich es noch an.
So, wunderbar.
Also.
Ich habe ein bisschen Audio-Settings rumgestellt.
Also es könnte sein, dass das jetzt irgendwie sich komisch anhört.
Sollte aber nicht.
Also, theoretisch sollte es sich besser anhören als vorher.
Sollte sich gleichmäßiger anhören als vorher.
Ich kann euch gleich mal zeigen, was ich eingestellt habe.
Vielleicht ist ja irgendwie der Audio-Pro am Start, der weiß, was ich da überhaupt gemacht habe.
Ah, ja, ja.
So.
Und zwar, ich habe Sound-Settings eingestellt.
Weil das letzte Mal hat ja jemand erzählt, Musik ist ein bisschen lauter.
Wobei, jetzt kann ich die Musik sogar lauter machen, weil ich bin gleichmäßiger laut.
Guckt mal.
Ich bin viel gleichmäßiger laut.
Seht ihr das?
Selbst wenn ich jetzt leiser rede, dann macht er das...
Ah.
Also, das müsste sich jetzt deutlich angenehmer anhören, weil ich nicht mehr so viele Audioschwankungen drin habe.
Ich höre mich anders...
Ja, ich weiß, ich höre mich ein bisschen anders an.
Ich habe aber nichts großartig drin.
Also, ich habe kein Noise-Gate drin.
Soll ich mal...
Ey, wenn ich mein Noise-Gate anmache, ist es richtig hängen geblieben.
Wartet mal.
Bist du krank?
Ne?
Ich habe...
Ich habe einen Kompressor reingemacht.
Das...
Ähm...
Ich möchte gleichmäßiger anhören.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass ich mich mal krank anhöre, dann muss ich das hier anmachen.
Warte mal.
Das hier.
Da höre ich mich richtig krank an, ja?
Das ist richtig kaputt, wenn ich das hier anschalte, oder?
Das hört sich einfach kaputt an.
Deswegen, das lasse ich mal.
Das lasse ich mal raus.
Wir können...
Wir gucken mal.
Also, es ist immer eine Sache...
Oh, huge.
Musik.
Okay, die Musik ist noch ein bisschen laut.
So.
Und deswegen...
Also, ich höre mich jetzt...
Ich höre mich jetzt gleichmäßiger an.
Und ich habe mal eingebaut, dass ich nicht mehr übersteuern kann.
Das kam mir manchmal vor, wenn ich überhusten musste oder so.
Dann habe ich übersteuert.
Aber das greift eh erst hier vorne irgendwo ein.
Also, sprich, ob ich das jetzt rein oder raus mache, ist vollkommen egal.
Moment.
Sollte das nicht eigentlich...
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Man sollte überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen.
Das sollte erst...
World say we are...
Oh, danke schön.
Twitch Prime.
Huge sub.
Das sollte erst...
Also, Achtung.
Wenn ich jetzt zu laut bin, dann...
Dann hört sich das so an.
Und wenn ich das hier rein mache, dann kann ich gar nicht zu laut sein.
So.
So weit von der Theorie.
Valorant Meinung.
Ich finde es...
Ich habe es nicht ausprobiert.
Ich weiß, dass heute die Beta startet.
Die Ubuntu-Beta.
Nee, die Valorant-Beta startet auch.
Lustigerweise, aber auch die...
Auch die...
Ju...
Ju-Bantu-Beta-Pilz-Schema ist auch am Start.
Zwei Monate schon.
Huge.
High IQ-Sub.
Ich habe mein Meme-Bot noch gar nicht gestartet.
Es startet nicht.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Nee.
Wo ist es denn?
Ich habe, glaube ich, meine...
Oh, wie ging das?
IP...
Windows ist IP-Config, ne?
Meine IP hat sich geändert.
Ich habe jetzt auf einmal aus mir nicht näher...
näher ersichtlichen Gründen...
habe ich auf einmal die IP hier.
Wow.
Riesen...
Riesen-Eier, ja.
Massive-Eier, ja.
So.
Guckt ihr?
Das...
Oh, ich habe das Limitieren gar nicht mehr an.
Aber es geht trotzdem nicht über minus 5.
Wahnsinn.
Ja, was auch immer ich da eingestellt habe, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aber...
Also, ich sollte mich jetzt deutlich gleichmäßiger anhören als vorher.
Das ist, äh, ist, ist, glaube ich, ist, glaube ich, angenehmer.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Ähm, so.
Jetzt müssen wir noch einmal schnell den...
Das Memeboard starten.
Ne, das ist nicht das.
Was erzähle ich für einen Scheiß?
Ähm...
Ihr wisst, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das Chat-Aufzeichnen-Programm starten, weil sonst übersehe ich wieder alles Mögliche.
Wen haben wir denn noch am Start?
Das Pilzschema.
Nee, Pilzschema hatten wir schon.
Aber trotzdem hier.
Zwei Monate.
Huge Sub.
Und World Savior auch.
Wahnsinnige High-IQ-Subs heute wieder.
Ja.
Das Endzone-Spiel scheint wohl gut auf Steam gestartet zu sein.
Ah ja, Echtzeitstrategie kann, kann man eigentlich nie genug haben.
Oh.
Run.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
So.
Jetzt werden wir den Kram erst einmal löschen.
Die Fragen vom letzten Stream.
Weil...
Ich glaube, wir haben alles.
Hatten alles vom letzten Mal.
So.
Gut.
So, und Chat, jetzt refreshe ich euch mal kurz.
Ich muss euch mal kurz refreshen.
Weil ich sehe nicht, wie viele Leute da sind.
So.
Perfekt.
Also...
Jutsch.
Bock.
Ähm.
Gut.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sollte alles passen.
Also, also Leute, wir müssen auch mal ein bisschen gucken, was Audio-Einstellungen angeht.
Wenn ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zu leise, zu laut, zu abgehackt, zu sonst was bin, dann gucken wir.
Ja, müssen wir mal schauen.
Das Einzige, was echt sagt, ist, da ich festgestellt habe, und das ist keinem bisher irgendwie aufgefallen, mir ist das erst...
Weil normalerweise höre ich mich ja nicht, nicht selbst.
Also, ich, ich höre mich selbst allerdings nicht über den gleichen Weg, wie ihr mich hört.
Also, ich hoffe, ihr versteht, was ich meine.
Ähm, und deswegen ist mir nie aufgefallen, dass dieses komische Audio-Interface, was ich verwende, für, da, da, wo das Mikrofon für den Stream reingeht, dass das übelst rauscht.
Total beschissen.
Das, das ist das übelste Rauscher-Man, ähm, Staat.
Und das ist mir nie aufgefallen, weil ich höre mich ja über den zweiten Weg, der nicht rauscht.
Also, das Mikrofon...
Das Mikrofon rauscht nicht, sondern das Aufnehmen rauscht.
Also, vom, von dem Audio-Interface, was ich hier am, am, am Gaming- beziehungsweise Spielerechner dran hab.
Das sackt.
So.
Das hat aber irgendwie noch keiner gemerkt, dass ich rausche.
Das heißt, ich rausche jetzt auch, aber ihr merkt es anscheinend nicht, dass ich rausche.
Chat muss noch mehr subben für mehr IQ, dass man das Rauschen irgendwann hört.
Oder vielleicht, vielleicht ist ja mittlerweile auch so, dass man nicht nur IQ steigern kann, sondern auch, äh, hören.
Durch Subs.
Vielleicht hört man dann das Rauschen irgendwann auch.
Zumindest, ich hab das beim Probehören festgestellt, es rauscht.
Das, äh, hat ziemlich gesackt.
So, was macht denn Unity Media?
Jo, jo, oh, Leute.
Null Frames dropped.
Null.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Das ist massive.
Huge.
Okay, ich glaub, die Musik macht das einen Ticken leiser.
So.
Sehr gut.
Und ich hab mich, ich hab mich schon ein bisschen leiser gemacht hier.
Sag mal.
Geht die Musik irgendwie ein bisschen vom Audio in das Mikro rein?
Weil, ich hab das Gefühl, wenn die Musik hier an ist, dann höre ich die Musik immer.
Wartet mal, das muss ich mal checken.
Okay, wir sind hier bei minus 35 gerade.
Das können wir, das können wir ganz einfach checken.
Wir machen die Musik aus.
Nö, das ist mein Gerausche.
Das ist mein Gerausche.
Wie gesagt, ich sag ja, das Audiointerface rauscht, aber irgendwie hat es noch keiner gemerkt.
Weiß auch nicht, warum.
Aber, aber eins müsst ihr sagen, ich bin, ich bin schon gleichmäßiger jetzt, oder?
Also vom Sound her bin ich gleich, gleichmäßiger.
Wobei, ich, ich sollte eigentlich nicht ins Rote gehen, das ist schlecht.
Kannst du deinen Boomer Messenger-Tweet noch, noch weiter ausführen?
Kann ich machen.
Was willst du wissen?
Vielleicht können wir einfach auch den Output-Gain noch ein bisschen runter machen, weil ich bin ganz schön laut hier.
Jetzt bin ich aber zu leise.
Ne, 10er, 10er Output.
Das war schon...
Dezibel ist eine richtige Scheißeinheit, hab ich dir schon mal gesagt.
Wer sich die
Das ist so
Das scaled so scheiße
So nach dem Motto
Dreimal mehr ist doppelt so laut
Und solche komischen Dinger
Naja ist es ja nicht ganz
Aber so merkwürdig irgendwie
So ich glaube
Mit 10 war ein bisschen laut oder
Ich mach nochmal kurz 10
So 10 ist ein bisschen laut oder
So hier weil wenn ich da jetzt mal
Irgendwie ein bisschen lauter
Huste dann wird es schon ein bisschen laut
Also soll ich so lassen
Soll ich auf 10 stellen oder soll ich
Soll ich lieber auf 7 stellen von der Lautstärke her
So
So oder so
10 ist top okay
Weil
Im Prinzip
Also was jetzt natürlich richtiger Fail ist
Was mir jetzt gerade auffällt ist
Wenn ich schreie
Passiert auch nicht viel
Also es sollte da muss ich das Ding hier anmachen
Es sollte eigentlich gut funktionieren
Es sollte eigentlich
Gut funktionieren also sprich
Selbst wenn ich jetzt
Ultralaut rede
Dann dann geht das nicht auf null
Das sollte das sollte der Kompressor eigentlich halbwegs
Händeln
Hört sich zwar der Kacke an
Aber
Es sollte nicht überstehen
Also nicht doch es kommt schon überstehen
Aber es sollten euch nicht die Ohren rausfallen
So wir laden wir wissen was
Wir lassen es einfach so genug rumgespielt
Gucken wir uns erstmal eine aktuelle
Jubantu an
Jau
Was auch immer
So
Mal kurz
Also
Ähm
Es hat mich ja irgendjemand gerade gefragt
Was ich zu
Valorant oder wie
Wie spricht man das eigentlich aus
Valorant
Wie auch immer
Valor von Mut und so
Mutig oder so
Kein Schimmer
Ähm
Wie hast du eigentlich den Follower Alert
Das ist Steamlabs
Das ist einfach einfach eins zu eins fertig so
Da kann man einfach das kann man einfach anklicken und dann dann sieht so aus
Ist es bei euch auch so oder ist mein Ohr kaputt
Bin ich bin ich links ein bisschen bisschen lauter als rechts
Nee oder
Ich ich ich glaub mal ich glaub mein mein mein Ohr spackt
Ich glaub da ist kein Unterschied
Ähm
Ja also ich
Wie gesagt ich hab dazu noch keine
Mir noch keine wahnsinnig äh wahnsinnige Meinung gebildet weil
Dein Mic ist Mono das geht nicht
Das stimmt
Das ist richtig
Wobei
Richtige Hexer können auch Mono Mix links und rechts unter
Also ich kann ich kann jetzt ja splitten
Ich kann ja einfach aus einem Mono zwei Audiospuren machen
Und die eine leiser machen
Das ist zwar nicht das liegt dann zwar nicht am Mikrofon
Das wär dann
Ähm
Kann ich nichts kann ich nichts zu sagen
Zu Valorant
Ähm
Was ich
Ich also was ich bisher gesehen habe was
Also eine Sache finde ich da ganz gut dran
Und zwar
Das ähm
Man wohl gesagt hat
Man man will weniger Overwatch sein mehr CS
Und da muss ich sagen das finde ich prinzipiell gut
Ja
Weil
Mir persönlich
Ist ja an Overwatch auch
Am Ende auf den Keks gegangen dass Overwatch so viel Overwatch war
Ich weiß nicht ob man mir jetzt geistig folgen konnte
Klang jetzt wir
Ja ich weiß
Aber
Am Anfang war Overwatch für mich ein Game wo man sagen konnte ja
Es wurden
Also die Helden
Die wo man halt auch
Sag mal Shooter spielen können musste
Die waren auch gut
Ja
Da konnte man mit McCree gut abgehen mit Soldier gut abgehen teilweise
Es war nicht so dieses dieses ähm
Melee Stun Hammer Meta was danach gekommen ist
Ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aussieht
Und es fand ich halt doof dass sich Overwatch so in die Richtung entwickelt hat
Das ähm
So viel
So viel nicht Shooter Charaktere am Start waren
Und das scheint ja in World 100 nicht zu sein
Also sprich die wollen wohl mehr CS sein
Als Overwatch
Und das finde ich gut
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen
Aber es ist nicht gerade die Beta gestartet
Wo kann man eigentlich die Beta den Beta Beta download hier
Download
Da
No
Ne ne
Moment mal
Da
So wir wollen
Wir wollen nämlich einmal
Wir wollen einmal das Desktop Image
Und einmal wollen wir den Server Installer
Wir wollen nämlich beides mal ausprobieren
Weil sie haben angeblich viel am Server Installer gemacht
Jede Woche eine andere Meta
Ja
Das finde ich gut
Das das braucht Overwatch
Das hat Overwatch gebraucht
Vor allem halt in Kombination mit das Blizzard
Früher zumindest
Ich weiß dass es mittlerweile besser ist
Früher gefühlt halt so gepatcht hat
Dass du ein halbes Jahr lang den gleichen Meta Kack spielen musstest
Und das hat halt keinem so richtig gefallen
So aber jetzt
Ich müsste mich doch im Großen und Ganzen anhören wie sonst oder
Bloß bloß halt
Bloß halt ein bisschen gleichmäßiger
Weil wenn ich mich richtig beschissen anhören soll
Dann würde ich das hier anmachen
Und das hört sich nämlich richtig beknackt an
Wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich neues
Wenn ich neue Suppression anmache
Wenn ich wenn ich neue Suppression ausmache
Klingt aber
Das klingt richtig scheiße
Das klingt richtig hänggeblieben
Lul
Hoch
Wow
MonkaS
Was ist jetzt los
Vodafone
Oder oder
Torrent nehmen
Ne wir starten den Download einfach neu
Eats
We try
Bam
Fuck
Leute ich weiß was
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was
Wir machen jetzt
Big Brain Download Magic
Und zwar
Wir gehen jetzt hier auf unsere Linux VM
Ich kopiere mir mal die Uhrl
Wo ist denn die Uhrl hier
Zum Desktop Image
Lautstärke passt
Ich kopiere mir mal die Uhrl zum Desktop Image
Und jetzt machen wir hier den da
Bam
Der lädt nämlich mit mehreren
Mit mehreren äh
Dings hier gleichzeitig runter
Easy
Guck und schon sind wir bei 49 Sekunden
Eats
Easy
Easy as fuck
E-e-e-e-easy as fuck
Das sind schon sind wir bei 34 Sekunden fertig
Der macht einfach glaub
Default mäßig keine Ahnung 12 Verbindungen
Oder so auf
Poggers
Der Michael 50 Billionen ist wieder am Start
Ah ja ja
Ähm
Jemand hat gefragt
Was an ZFS so gut ist
Da werde ich mal kurz was zu sagen
Während der Kram runter lädt
Drunter lädt GitHub
Äh äh äh Linux
Ich glaube die haben nämlich eine ganz gute Übersicht
Ansonsten kann ich meine Erfahrung berichten
Nur weil nur ich will mir jetzt nur mal an der Seite angucken
Dass ich kein Bullshit erzähle
Und die Hälfte vergesse
Ähm
Anscheinend haben die keine schöne Übersicht
Also was
Was hat ZFS im Vergleich zu normalen Filesystemen
Für für Vorteile
Wir fangen
Wir fangen erstmal an
Mit äh
Den Nachteilen
Würde ich sagen
Äh ZFS ist relativ komplex
Ja also sprich
ZFS hat 30 Milliarden Stellschrauben
Und du kannst Gott und die Welt einstellen
Und
Bis vor kurzem
Konnte man auch im ZFS nicht erweitern
Ich glaube da sind sie gerade dran
Und vielleicht ist es im aktuellen Release schon drin
Weiß ich nicht müssen wir mal gucken
Man konnte den ZFS Pool lange Zeit nicht erweitern
Es sei denn
Ähm
Also den ZFS Raid
Es sei denn
Man hat quasi
Das gleiche nochmal reingesteckt
Also sprich man hatte nen Pool
Oder nen Raid
Aus irgendwie
Drei Platten
Und da musste man dann nochmal drei Platten
Dazu machen
Und das spiegeln
Dann konnte man das erweitern
Aber das war nicht schön
Also ZFS war in der Verwaltung her
In allem ein bisschen
Ein bisschen over the top
Ja
Aber sie sind
Sie sind wirklich gut dabei
Das ganze anzupassen
Oh guck mal
Kopieren ist fertig
Pok
Ähm
So
Und
Dann noch ein noch ein weiteres
Nachteil
Von
ZFS
Ist
Im Vergleich
Zu normalen
Zwar normalen
Filesystemen
Sowas wie
X4
Oder oder
XFS
Oder
Solche Dinger
Ähm
Dass das viel RAM verbraucht
Also
Es wird empfohlen
Dass
Ähm
Dass man
ZFS
Quasi
Standard
Ich glaub standardmäßig
Ratio
Ist eingestellt
Die Hälfte des RAMs
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ähm
Aber
ZFS
Möchte
Sehr viel RAM
Haben
Man muss aber dazu sagen
Da ist
Da kursieren
Also da kursieren im Internet
Viele
Merkwürdige Guides
So nach dem Motto
Unter 48 GB
Sollte man kein ZFS einsetzen
Das ist kompletter Blödsinn
Ja
Du kannst ZFS einfach mit
Mit
Stinknormalen
8G
Oder 4G
Einsetzen
Das
Da muss ich halt nur gucken
Dass man sich dadurch auch ein paar Einbußen holt
Wenn man halt
Viele User
Und parallele Zugriffe hat
Und dann
Sein
Pfeilsauber hat
Den vielleicht zwei drei Leute verwenden gar nicht hat
Ähm
Dann
Gibt's noch eine weitere Sache
Dass
Man
Nach Möglichkeit
ECC
RAM
Verwenden soll
Für ZFS
Ist aber auch
Nicht so ganz richtig
Ähm
Wenn man halt
Die
Stärken
Von
ZFS
Wirklich
Noch weiter ausbauen will
So dass
ZFS
Irgendwie schlechter wird
Ohne ECC
RAM
Also wenn man das vergleicht
Mit einem normalen Fallsystem
Wo du beispielsweise Fehler nicht
Nicht rechtzeitig feststellen
Oder wo Fehler überhaupt
Passieren können
Dann
Dreht den ZFS
Nicht auf einmal Fehler auf
Nur weil man kein
ECC
RAM
Hat
So
Und auch
Auch ein Giga
Ist genau
Das gibt's auch
Oft so ein Gigabyte RAM
Pro Terabyte
Und sowas in der Richtung
Kann man alles machen
Weil sich das halt
Das Empfehlungen sind
Wenn man das wirklich
Auch unter ordentlich
Last
Mit vielen Leuten
Und Parallelen
Zugriffen betreiben will
Daheim
Kommt man auch
Ohne Probleme
Mit einer ziemlich
Schwachbrüstigen Kiste
Und ZFS
Aus
Dann hat man zwar nicht
Die wahnsinns Performance
Und ist wahrscheinlich
Sogar ein Ticken
Langsamer
Rein was
IO
Angeht
Und Zugriffszeiten
Wie wenn man das jetzt klassisch
Macht mit einer SSD
Und einfach XFS drauf
Oder X4 drauf
Und das kommt
Zu den Vorteilen
ZFS
Hat auch
Jede Menge Vorteile
Ich suche mal nebenbei
Eine Liste
Nicht dass ich die Hälfte
Oder vergesse
Das erste
Was für mich
Sehr praktisch ist
Ist das
Alles eingebaut
Ist in ZFS
RAID
Ist eingebaut
So mal
Ob es ordentlich
Oder
Was heißt
Vorteile auf Englisch
Leute
Ich stehe gerade
Auf dem Schlauch
Features
Wieso nach Features
In dem Fall
Besser
In den Features
Wie kommen wir
Zu Features
So
Aber erstmal
Meine Eindrücke
Zu ZFS
Also eins
Was für mich
Ein Riesenvorteil ist
Es ist in ZFS
Alles eingebaut
Du hast
Jetzt fange ich auch schon an
Mit du hast
Ich kriege immer Anfälle
Wenn die Leute
Auf YouTube Videos
Leute mit du anreden
Ich zeige dir heute
Wie du deine Fritzbox
Einrichtest
Als erstes
Musst du sicherstellen
Dass die Fritzbox
Am Netzwerk
Angeschlossen ist
Das ist der Ausschlag
Wenn ich die Leute immer so höre
Man sagt
Man sagt ihr
Man redet nicht mit einem
Man selbst ist einer
Und redet mit
Keine Ahnung
Hunderten
Tausenden
Zehntausenden
Was auch immer
Ich mag das nicht
Wenn die Leute direkt
Angeredet werden
In den Videos
So
Und
Bei ZFS
Ist halt alles dabei
Sprich
Verschlüsselung
Ist eingebaut
Raid
Snapshots
Sind eingebaut
Also alles
Was man irgendwie braucht
Für Filesharing
Ist eingebaut
Also
Sowas wie Samba
Und sowas
Auch wenn es unter Linux
Standardzeug verwendet
NFS ist eingebaut
Es ist quasi
Alles
Standardmäßig
Drin
Was man
Was man irgendwie so braucht
Das ist
Riesenvorteil
Von ZFS
Dann hat
Dann hat es noch jede Menge
Weitere Sachen
Die wie gesagt
Die Snapshot
Geschichte
Anderes
Neues Mikro
Hört man das
Roffel
Also
Ich hab nicht wirklich
Ich hab
Ich hab kein anderes Mikro
Ich hab mal den Kompressor
Eingeschaltet
Dass ich jetzt ungefähr
Einheitlich
Dass ich jetzt
Hört sich besser an
Ja
Dass ich einheitlicher bin
Dass ich mich einheitlicher anhöre
Sehr viel besser
Ah
Excellent
Exquisite
Können wir gleich richtig los
Hacks hören
Ähm
Genau
So
Dann geht es weiter
Was was auch noch eine tolle Sache ist
Das ist
Das
Also
Wenn
из
Ist
Also
Wo
Alles
Die
Anzahl
So
Ist
In
Der
Karte
Ist
Das
Genau
Is
Das
Ist
So
Das ist eine super Geschichte. Und ZFS-Snapshots kosten auch keinen Speicherplatz. ZFS-Snapshots kannst du tausende anlegen, die kosten alle keinen Speicherplatz. Die fangen erst an, Speicherplatz zu kosten, wenn das Delta zwischen ursprünglichem Zeitpunkt und Snapshot, also was geschrieben wurde, sehr groß wird.
Also du kannst mit ZFS 300 Snapshots machen, die kosten alle keinen Speicherplatz. Die kosten erst Speicherplatz, umso älter sie werden, umso mehr passiert, umso mehr zwischen dem Snapshot-Zeitpunkt und jetzt halt passiert ist.
Deswegen ist es eine super Geschichte, wenn ich ein großes Upgrade mache oder mal angenommen, ich habe einen Server, wo ich noch so oldschool bin und da irgendwie mehrere Kunden drauf habe und die sind nicht in Containern und sonst was, dann mache ich da einfach Snapshot.
Snapshot.
Und lösche die einfach der Reihe nach wieder.
Aber ich habe erstmal unmittelbar die Sicherheit, dass ich einfach wieder zurückrollen kann.
Geht das auch auf ein Ubuntu 16.04?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob 16.04 schon ZFS dabei hat.
Also 18.04 hat auf jeden Fall ZFS dabei, aber 16.04 bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Also anscheinend nicht offiziell.
Naja.
Aber 16.04 ist doch eh dieses Jahr End of Life, oder?
Oh ne, ich habe nichts gesagt, Leute.
Fuck läuft das.
Das ist lang.
Alter, der Scheiß läuft ja lang, ey.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Es ist sogar, guck mal, 14.04 ist noch supported bis 2002.
Wahnsinn.
Und das alles umsonst.
Da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Bei den Ubuntu-Hacksorn.
So, ähm, dann noch ein Riesenvorteil von ZFS im Vergleich zu den meisten anderen Dateisystemen ist, dass dir nicht einfach so...
Ich...
Ich muss da ein bisschen...
Ich muss da ein bisschen zurück...
Also die Aussage ist...
Die ist nicht so schlimm, wie es sich jetzt anhört.
Also es ist nicht so, dass wenn du andere Filesysteme verwendest, dass dein Zeug kaputt geht oder so.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Aber es kann kaputt gehen, ohne dass du es mitbekommst.
Also wenn jetzt deine Festplatte irgendeinen Fehler hat und ein paar Sektoren sind kaputt und dadurch vielleicht ein paar Dateien beschädigt,
dann kriegt das normale Filesystem nicht so ohne weiteres mit.
Das kriegt es dann erst mit, wenn du ein Filesystem-Check machst.
Wenn du Glück hast.
Und wenn du Glück hast, kannst du auch recoveren.
Bei ZFS ist das kein Problem.
ZFS hat für alles Checksum.
Und kriegt alles mit.
Also sprich, ZFS geht eher kaputt, bevor deine Dateien kaputt gehen.
Oder besser gesagt, ZFS geht eher read-only, bevor deine Dateien kaputt gehen.
So, ähm...
So, was haben die...
Was sagen die denn selbst noch für Vorteile?
Ähm, weil ich vergesse wahrscheinlich wieder die Hälfte.
Genau, Checksum.
Das ist das, was ich gerade erkläre.
Copy and write.
Das ist das, was ich meinte, dass erst mal initial nichts Speicher braucht.
Erst, wenn es abweicht.
Ähm, Snapshots hatten wir auch schon.
Pool Data Storage.
Ja, man kann jede Menge...
Sag mal, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Oder, ne, passt.
Dafür bin ich ja heute gleichmäßig lauter.
Bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, dem das Super Mario Theme nicht gefällt?
Ich komme mir da immer wieder übelste Game-Musik-Banause vor,
aber ich mag das Super Mario Theme überhaupt nicht.
Ähm, man kann...
Man kann total abgedrehte Sachen machen mit, ähm...
Volumes und Datasets und Gedöns.
Also, man kann das sehr schön gruppieren und managen das Ganze.
ZFS hat auch extrem viele Tuning-Optionen, was man machen kann.
Lautstärke passt.
Also, von Kompression bis Deduplication, da ist alles möglich.
Wobei man diese Sachen mit Vorsicht genießen muss.
Gerade Deduplication braucht wirklich enorm viel RAM.
Kompression kann man eigentlich auf aktuellen CPUs bedenkenlos einschalten.
Dann ist, ähm, ganze RAID-Geschichte mit eingebaut.
Das heißt, man braucht auch kein, ähm, irgendwie MD-RAID, kein LUX und Gedöns.
Man kann quasi RAID und Encryption jetzt alles in einem machen.
So.
Genau.
Das ist auch, das ist auch eine coole Geschichte.
Man kann eine SSD als Cache verwenden.
Also, sprich, wenn man, wenn man irgendwie eine RAID 5 hat,
oder eine RAID 10, oder irgendwas mit, oder RAID 6 mit vielen, vielen Platten drinne,
und das jetzt nicht das Allerschnellste ist,
dann kann man dafür sorgen, dass das erstmal gecached wird auf eine SSD und dann weggeschrieben.
Die haben Terminologie, die ich bis heute nicht ganz gecheckt hab, was da was ist.
Schaust du immer auf deine verbrauchte Leistung auf deinem PC?
Nö.
Du meinst Stromverbrauch? Nö.
An dem, am normalen PC hab ich gar nichts angeschlossen.
Wo ich was angeschlossen hab, ist hier an der, an der Kiste hinter mir.
So, ähm, genau.
Man kann extrem viel Speicher, äh, kann extrem viel Speicherplatz in einem ZFS.
Allerdings muss man sagen, ich, mir, mir fällt kein Anwendungszweck ein,
wo ich mal an das Speicherlimit von einem XFS oder einem X4 gestoßen wäre.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das liegt.
Also, zumindest kann ZFS 256 Quadrillionen, äh, Zetabyte, ne, oder?
Zetabyte speichern.
Was auch immer das ist.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Es ist viel.
Ja, äh, aber so viel.
Es, ist wurscht.
Äh, ich glaub, man hat jetzt gesehen, dass, das hat seine Daseinsberechtigung, ähm,
vielleicht jetzt nicht auf so einer normalen, auf normalen Desktop.
Wobei es da auch seine Vorteile haben kann.
Ähm, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache.
Hast du etwas zu dem Thema studiert?
Ne.
Soll man was zu ZFS studieren?
Ja.
Server-Installer oder dem Desktop-Installer.
Wir gucken uns erstmal den Desktop-Installer
an, weil der ist angeblich auch viel besser.
Ähm.
Bla, bla.
Yes, later Linux.
Ubuntu 64.
Ähm.
Das Ganze erstellen wir unter
E-Doppelpunkt
VMS.
Äh.
What?
Bin ich doof gewesen?
Oh, ich
hab da kein Unterverzeichnis gemacht.
Ich hab es direkt da reingeschrieben.
Sehr clever, Max.
Big Brains, meine
Verzeichnisstruktur.
Ähm.
Dann machen wir weiter, weiter,
weiteres Big Brain.
Pass mal auf.
Bam. So. Sehr gut.
So muss das sein.
4 CPUs. 16G RAM.
Nee, 16MB.
16G. Ach, das geht da hier nicht.
Oh.
16G RAM.
Weil es geht.
Nicht, weil man es braucht.
Einfach, weil es funktioniert.
Next.
Create Disk.
Single.
60 GB.
Speichert er.
Nee, nicht da.
ETF. E. Doppelpunkt.
VMS. 2.
Da sollst du speichern, nicht bei mir auf der Platte.
So, den Drucker schmeißen wir raus.
Den Drucker schmeißen wir immer raus.
Accelerate 3D Graphics.
Sounds. Dings. Na, das ist close.
Yes. Excellent.
Auf geht's.
Ist das noch derselbe Server,
was du auf deinem YouTube-Kanal vorgestellt hast?
Die ZFS-Kiste schon, ja.
Aber, wie gesagt, da läuft nichts mehr drauf.
Die habe ich soweit
abgelöst, dass ich sie eigentlich
nicht mehr brauche.
Durch was viel billigeres,
viel kleineres, viel stromsparendes,
allerdings halt auch viel leistungsschwächeres.
Aber das war einfach komplett
overkill, was ich mir da zusammengebastelt habe.
Ich meine, das ist keine Kiste,
die bei uns im Rechenzentrum steht.
Das ist was für mich daheim.
Ich habe viel mehr Leistung da reingebaut,
weil ich total übertrieben habe,
wie ich eigentlich
gebraucht hätte.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal Chat gucken.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen übersehen.
Was hältst du von QLC-SSDs?
Kann ich nicht viel zu sagen.
Zumindest nicht qualifiziert.
Was? Disks?
Welche Disks willst du denn bitte
schon checken?
Da ist überhaupt keine Disks drin.
Außer die leere.
Die leere Disc ist drin.
Okay, dann checke mal leere Disks.
Oh, okay.
Big Brain Ubuntu.
Hättest du den zum Rechenzentrum gebracht...
Erschreckt mich nicht so.
Erschreckt mich nicht so, Ubuntu.
Was soll das?
So, ähm,
Englisch, Install,
äh, Keyboard Layout. Nee, nee, nee.
Äh, äh, German.
German.
No. Dead Key.
Das brauchen wir. Continue.
Äh, okay, also.
Das ist jetzt anscheinend neu.
Ich habe schon ehrlich gesagt, so Hand aufs Herz,
wie das da Kaboom früher immer schön gesagt hat.
Ich habe schon lange
kein Ubuntu Desktop mehr installiert.
Oh, ich noob.
Ich habe die Stream vor allem ausgeschaltet.
Nein, der Chatlogger
funktioniert ja sonst nicht mehr.
WTF, das geht ja nicht.
570 IQ.
Der Basti schreibt, ähm,
es gab mal eine Berechnung, dass mit aktuellen HDDs
die Menge an Speicherplatz, die komplette Menge
alles Wassers auf der Erde benötigen würde
zur Kühlung.
Aha.
Also, wir sind in Deutschland, normalerweise berechnen wir Sachen
in Fußballfelder. Da kann, das können wir uns
irgendwie besser vorstellen.
Ähm,
ich muss mal kurz im Chat durchscrollen,
ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Irgendwas sollte ich vorher näher ausführen.
Ich habe mal eine Frage.
Vielleicht hast du
oder der Chat eine Lösung.
Und zwar muss ich irgendwie Internet übers LAN
von, also schreibt der Meister
proper, ähm,
Internet übers LAN von
einem Raum über zwei andere Räume
zu meinem Büro bringen.
Findest du, dass das Powerline
eine gute Lösung ist?
Das kommt aufs Haus an, ob Powerline
eine gute Lösung ist.
Ähm, aber zeige ich mal.
Du willst irgendwie
was? Zwar muss ich irgendwie Internet
über das LAN von einem
Raum über zwei andere Räume
zu, warum, warum
nicht einfach WLAN?
Also so schlecht, wenn du nicht spielen willst,
ist WLAN nur wirklich nicht übel.
Und selbst mal spielen,
man, WLAN ist an sich
eh besser als ein Ruf.
Ähm,
Powerline ist auf jeden Fall eine Option, wenn das
gut funktioniert. Bei dir kommt es ein bisschen aufs Haus an.
Ansonsten
gibt es ja nicht viele Varianten, ja.
Was willst du großartig machen? Powerline?
WLAN?
Du wirst dir weder
eine Mikrowelle noch Richtfunk
noch, ähm,
eine Glasfaserleitung
irgendwie in der Straße mieten wollen.
Keine Ahnung. Es gibt ja ansonsten nicht
viele Varianten, was du machen kannst.
So, ich glaube, ich habe nichts mehr übersehen soweit.
Was hältst du von USB-Sticks,
die sich als Datentresor ausgeben mit
FIPS-Verschlüsselung etc.?
Ähm, da gibt es ein paar gute Sachen.
Ich habe einen, ähm,
Fuck, wie hieß das Ding?
Äh, Ubi, Ubi
Dings, äh, Key?
Ubi Key
hieß das, genau.
Der liegt hier irgendwo rum
und liegt vor sich hin.
Habe ich noch nicht
benutzt, aber die soll ganz gut sein.
Schon mal ein Hackintosh
installiert. Ich habe es probiert auf einer ganz
alten Kiste, die liegt hier übrigens immer noch unter dem Tisch.
Und da hatte Mac ein Problem
mit der integrierten Grafikkarte und seitdem habe ich die
nie wieder angefasst. Ja, also, wie gesagt,
zu der ganzen, zu der, zu der, äh,
Router-Thematik.
Ich würde, ich würde gucken, ob man das nicht mit WLAN
machen kann. WLAN ist okay.
Man kann gegen WLAN eigentlich nicht, nicht,
nicht viel sagen. Es muss ja,
also, wenn du Probleme hast,
ähm,
oder, oder dich stört,
WLAN-Sticks oder WLAN an den Rechnern
zu verwenden, du kannst natürlich auch einfach
WLAN, äh,
WLAN-Accesspoint hinstellen
und dort dann einen Switch anschließen und,
und an den Switch dann per Kabel. Die Rechnern funktionieren
auch. Oder du kaufst dir halt eine ordentliche,
ähm,
wie nennt man das?
Ähm,
so eine ordentliche Funkbrücke oder so.
Wie heißt denn das?
Irgend so ein Richtfunkding. Aber das braucht
man dafür gar nicht, wenn das einfach nur zwei,
zwei, zwei Räume weiter ist.
Wenn das nur zwei Räume
weiter ist, dann würde ich es
wahrscheinlich genau so machen. Ich würde
es über WLAN machen. Ich würde mir einen guten Accesspoint
holen. Auf der anderen Seite auch eine ordentliche
ordentliches Endgerät hinstellen.
Daran kommt wieder ein Switch und
daran kommen die Endgeräte. Fertig.
Dann braucht ja nicht jedes Endgerät einen WLAN-Stick.
Dann kannst du die Endgeräte
weiterhin per Kabel anschließen, aber
an sich geht es über WLAN.
So, machen wir weiter. Normale Installation, Minimale Installation.
Wir kommen uns mal an die Normale Installation. Download
Updates while Installing. Ja, perfekt.
Moment, wir müssen für die,
für die passende Ubuntu Experience
brauchen wir hier das hier.
Gleich besser, oder?
Gleich, gleich viel,
viel angenehmer. Chat,
oder? So, muss das sein.
Download Updates,
ja, installieren,
alles installieren. Next.
Next. Berlin sind wir.
Passt.
Your Name, cute.
Moment,
muss ich aufpassen. Leute,
ich hab, ich hab deutsch,
ist das noch verbuggt im Installer?
Ich hab deutsche,
Tastatur, Layout,
Chiller, Killer, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Bevor ich dir das erzähle,
was ich für ein Mikrofon verwende,
hast du meinen Stream vorher schon mal geguckt?
Weil, dann würde ich gerne von dir wissen,
ob du soundtechnisch
einen Unterschied hörst zwischen
heute und dem letzten Mal.
Oh, ich installiere mit XFS, fuck.
Ah.
Siehste, Chat,
ich hab nicht aufgepasst.
Neustart. Weg.
RIP.
Ja, nochmal neu. Wir haben ja noch nichts gemacht.
Wir haben ja noch nichts gemacht.
Ach.
Ja, ich weiß,
die Installation ist kaputt.
Oh, nicht schnell genug.
Jetzt die Quickscope-Reflexe, Leute.
Bam. Fuck.
Ich weiß, dass es anders geht.
Aber ich probiere das immer so, bis es klappt.
Ich weiß, dass es anders funktioniert.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
Ähm.
So. CD.
Sind deine
Wifi-USB-Power-Schalter schon angekommen?
Äh.
Welche waren das noch?
Also, ne, sind nicht angekommen.
Aber ich überlege gerade, welche das waren.
Ach, die.
Die ich letztens im Video gezeigt habe, wo man
USB-Geräte über das WLAN
ausschalten kann.
Die sind noch nicht angekommen.
Aber die haben auch gesagt, ich glaube,
Lieferzeitpunkt, ich meine, es ist aus China.
Die haben gerade andere Probleme,
als mir USB-Geräte zu liefern, glaube ich.
Aber die hatten auch
Lieferzeitpunkt irgendwie
26.04. oder sowas.
Ne, hast du nicht gesehen?
Also, ich habe ein MMX300 und das
ganz normale Headset-Mikrofon,
was da dran ist.
Ein Beyerdynamics MMX300 Headset.
Ich habe hier neben mir noch ein Blue Yeti-Mikrofon stehen.
Aber ich finde es
angenehmer,
das über das Headset-Mikro zu machen.
Von der Qualität her
wäre das
irgendwie besser.
Und ich habe sogar noch im Schrank irgendwo
damals, ich hatte mir
ein recht teures Mikrofon
für
Voice-Aufnahme für Videos damals gekauft.
Das war mir dann aber im Handling auch zu anstrengend.
So, ähm,
Englisch.
So, jetzt gucken wir, ob jetzt die deutsche Tastatur
funktioniert. German.
No dead keys.
So, wo kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt ZFS im Installer auswählen?
Wo kann man
jetzt im Installer das überhaupt auswählen? Wahrscheinlich
danach, wenn es ums Partitionieren geht.
Schauen wir mal.
Beste Musik.
Hier vielleicht, advanced features?
Ah!
Erase disk and use ZFS.
Was ist das hier? Ne, da kann ich es
von Hand machen.
Hier, das da.
Was, something else? Warum?
Warum sollte ich
something else machen? Ich will ja mal gucken, wie der,
dass ich es von Hand einrichten kann,
dachte ich mir, aber wir machen einfach mal das.
Ich will mal
gucken, was der macht, wenn man es automatisch auswählt.
Weil das werden ja auch die
meisten Noobs machen.
Okay, also, was machen,
was legt der an?
Ähm,
das ist eine Boot-Partition, nehme ich mal an.
Swap, B-Pool,
R-Pool.
Ist das, ist das für Boot? Macht der für
Boot ein eigenes,
einen eigenen
Pool? Gucken wir uns danach
an, wenn installiert ist.
Ich kann euch aber gleich sagen,
ich bin mit ZFS ein bisschen eingerostet,
was die Administration angeht,
weil auf der Arbeit verwenden wir kein ZFS mehr
und meine Kiste hier hinten mit ZFS,
mit den 3x10TB-Platten,
war ich schon fast in den Jahren
immer eingeloggt, hab was großartig drauf gemacht.
Aber so die Basics kriege ich noch zusammen.
Äh, abstürzen
macht der. Ich hab mit Ubuntu wenig
Schmerzen gehabt, im Serverbetrieb wohlgemerkt.
Desktop verwende ich es ja nicht.
Okay, ähm, was ist denn hier?
Qt Chat.
Passwort
123456, 123456.
Yes!
Excellent!
Okay, gucken wir da im Ganzen mal zu.
Nenn den
Account QtBoot
Machen wir beim nächsten installieren.
Ähm, jemand hat vorhin geschrieben, ich soll meinen
Boomer-Tweet von heute noch etwas
genauer ausführen.
Da muss ich erst mal überlegen, was ich da geschrieben hab.
Ach die Leute, ja, und zwar,
wir haben auf der Arbeit, Leute,
wir müssen ja alle zwangsläufig Homeoffice arbeiten jetzt.
Gibt's ja nix mehr vor Ort.
Ähm,
und
es tun sich, ich hab mich ja schon letztens drüber
ausgelassen im Stream,
dass die wahre Elite quasi MMO
Spieler sind. Die wissen einfach, wie man online
sinnvoll mit Leuten kommuniziert.
Die restlichen Leute sind da ziemlich
ziemliche Kack-Noobs.
Aber es gibt eine Gruppe von Leuten,
da ist es besonders schlimm. Und zwar die,
nicht unbedingt zu den
Boomer-Generationen,
das sind bei weitem auch davon
nicht alle und auch nicht nur
im Umkehrschluss, sondern die Leute,
die Instant Messenger so schreiben
und so verwenden, wie
E-Mail. Heute, ich kann mir
das nicht merken, ich muss es mal selbst zitieren
von meinem Twitter.
Ich muss es mal zitieren von meinem Twitter, und zwar
ähm, hier.
Guten Morgen,
Kollegen. Wir sehen zurzeit
einen Anstieg von Fehlern im Loadbalancer.
Bitte leiten Sie Entstörungsmaßnahmen ein.
Mit freundlichen Grüßen, Kollege XY.
Warum schreibt man
so im Instant Messenger?
Was ist, was,
was ist mit den Leuten los?
Ja, und
ja, was gibt's da großartig sonst noch zu erzählen?
Was soll, was ich noch weiter ausführen soll?
Das gibt da, es gibt da viel zu viele von.
Normalerweise.
Also ich hab mich ja letztens im Stream
ausgelassen, dass ja in Wirklichkeit,
was Homeoffice angeht und
ähm, Leute, die halt gut online
remote mit anderen zusammenarbeiten können,
dass die neue Elite quasi
MMO, Progress
Spieler ist, beziehungsweise
Competitive Spieler, Team
Competitive Spieler sind, die
eben gelernt haben, wie man
gut
und, und, und
ähm,
empathisch, nennen wir's mal, online
kommuniziert. Ich weiß, das klingt jetzt
weit hergeholt, zu dem
ganzen Geflame, was abge-
in Online-Games, aber wir reden ja hier von
Leute, die in nem festen
Team lange zusammenspielen können.
Also die müssen schon nen gewissen, gewissen Social
Online-Social-Skill
haben, dass das funktioniert, sonst würden sie ja laufen
überall gekickt werden, ja. Ich rede jetzt nicht
von den Leuten in nem random Game, die sagen,
alter, piss dich, äh, kack, ich fick deine Mutter.
Ja, die, die mein ich nicht.
Und die Leute sind das, die im Homeoffice
richtig gut arbeiten können und mit denen man auch
richtig gut kommunizieren kann.
Und, ähm, da sind auch nicht
die, die irgendwie schreiben, äh, hallo,
Kollegin der Lautbalenzer, blablabla,
mit freundlichen Grüßen, sondern die schreiben in
Instant Messenger einfach so, wie sie
in nem MMO schreiben würden, wenn
sie ne Raid-Gruppe suchen.
Halt halt, nicht Raid-Gruppe, sondern
halt was zur Technik. Und
wenn du in nem Messenger auf, im
Homeoffice zwei Leute hast,
die MMOs
irgendwie auf, auf, auf
Progress mit Raiden und sonst was gespielt haben,
dann reden die
im Homeoffice miteinander
über den Chat ungefähr so, wie wenn sie
ne Raid-Gruppe suchen in nem MMO.
Also sprich, einfach
so, dass man's versteht.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Und ich merk's immer wieder bei den Leuten, die keine Erfahrung
mit Online-Spielen haben, die kacken voll ab
im Homeoffice, was Kommunikation angeht.
So, jetzt müssen wir erst
einmal schauen, ob die vielleicht es
mittlerweile geschafft haben. Das ist ja
ne Sache, die geht mir bei Ubuntu schon seit
zig Versionen auf den Sack.
Ähm, ob die's...
Ah, sie haben's geschafft, Leute!
Endlich!
Sie haben's geschafft,
Forever Tools einzubauen.
Endlich! Da wart ich ja schon
ewig drauf. Ansonsten muss man
immer Forever Tools installieren.
Und es hat dann rumgespackt.
Das hier kann man übrigens nicht
verschieben.
Sie haben's geschafft, Forever Tools zu installieren.
Connect your online accounts.
Nope. Skip.
Live-Patch. Äh...
Setup Live-Patch. Was, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Ähm... Probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ähm...
Also, im Chat schreibt
iBandle
Ähm...
Also, ich habe das jetzt mal ausgerechnet.
Nehmen wir 10TB Low-Profile
3,5 Zoll HDDs, dann
brauchen wir... Alter, was ist das für ne Zahl?
3.600.000...
Nee, 364.000
98,7
Fußballfelder
nach den Abmaßen der Bundesliga, um eine
Max-Size ZFS Pool zu speichern.
Ah, excellent.
Quickmuffs.
Du hast dir eine Rolle Klopapier
verdient.
Für so viel Intelligenz
und Big Brain, High IQ im Chat.
Nicht schlecht.
Also, wir brauchen ganz schön...
Wir brauchen ganz schön viele Fußballfelder.
So, Live-Patch.
Was ist Live-Patch?
Genug Klo... Was?
Warum?
Ach! Ah!
Live-Patch. Ich bin...
Ich bin ja auch ein Kack-Nug.
Live-Patch ist nicht, dass der automatisch Updates installiert.
Live-Patch ist diese Geschichte,
dass du
manche Kernel-Updates
und sonstige Sachen
ohne Reboot machen kannst.
Stimmt, da war was.
So was haben die gehabt, ja.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Nein, wir wollen
Ubuntu
nicht, oder einfach auch Ubuntu.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Location Service...
Meinetwegen, mal gucken, was passiert.
You can...
Here you go.
Okay, das kann man nicht anklicken.
Das ist Fake, Fake, Fake-Klicker.
Fake-Anklicker ist das ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Wow!
What the fuck? Wow! Oh!
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht, glaub ich.
Also doch.
Hat nur gedauert.
Install.
Also man muss sagen, die Oberfläche
sieht mittlerweile wirklich recht polished aus.
Ich bin nach wie vor kein Fan
von dem Ubuntu-Farbschema.
Hat mir seit der ersten Version nicht gefallen.
Die erste Version war noch mehr braun, anstatt dieses
komische lila jetzt.
Die ersten Ubuntu-Versionen waren eher so braun-rot.
Install ging aber ziemlich zackig.
Guck mal,
man kann sogar, ähm,
Java-Gedöns installieren.
So, Visual Studio haben wir installiert. Discord kann man installieren.
Hieri.
Was ist denn Hieri?
Mail Client.
Mail. Mail in 2020.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Xfce, KDE, Plasma oder Gnome.
Das ist ziemlich sicher ein stinknormales
Gnome hier.
Oder meinst du, was ich davon nehmen würde?
Ich würde keins von den
drei nehmen. Aber wenn ich was
nehmen müsste, dann würde ich Xfce nehmen.
Ansonsten nehme ich
immer i3.
Es bin released. Do you want to install? Install.
Immer install.
Excellent install.
Wenn ich mich zwischen
den drei entscheiden müsste,
KDE Gnome oder Xfce, würde ich Xfce nehmen.
Aber eigentlich will ich
keins von drei verwenden, sondern nehme i3.
i3 beste.
Übrigens noch mal zur Anmerkung, weil das ein paar
haben wollten und ich weiß, dass
mit Sicherheit nicht alle im letzten
Stream dabei waren.
Für diejenigen, die es interessiert,
ich hab aus dem Arch,
äh, nicht Arch Linux, Manjaro,
gut, Manjaro Schrägstrich
Arch Linux Einricht
Stream, habe ich die
Config-Files bei mir auf GitHub gepusht.
Mit ein paar kleinen Anpassungen
noch dazu, weil das
einige Leute interessiert hat.
Könnt ihr gucken, wenn es euch
interessiert.
So, also, was gibt's denn
schönes Neues? Es gibt neue Icons.
Die finde ich eigentlich ganz hübsch.
Könnte ich mir auf einem anderen auch erzählen.
Die haben standardmäßig so ein
Zwischending, so ein halbes
Dark Theme ist es. So ein halbes Dark Theme.
Es ist kein richtiges Dark Theme,
es ist nur so ein halbes Dark Theme.
Der Hintergrund ist relativ dunkel,
das hier oben ist relativ dunkel, aber die
Nautilus und so, das ist alles hell.
Ja. So, Terminal.
Terminal wird ein stinknormales
Gnome-Terminal sein, vermute ich mal.
Ja.
Aber sieht ganz brauchbar aus.
Und es hat mittlerweile
keine komische Transparenz
mehr. Das finde ich ziemlich gut.
Den Default
Ubuntu-Font mochte ich eigentlich schon immer.
Ganz gut.
Und das Ubuntu-Font-Rendering sieht auch
wieder ganz okay aus. Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Machen wir es ein bisschen größer.
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Der Standard-Font ist gut.
Und das
Font-Rendering ist auch sehr ordentlich.
Da ist nix irgendwie Klötzchen oder
sonst wie. Das sieht echt gut aus.
Und wie sieht es klein aus?
Das sieht auch gut aus.
Das können die echt ganz gut bei
in Afrika
in Südafrika.
Also das sieht
okay aus. Das ist so ein Knopf da oben.
Achso, neuer Tab. Suchen.
Okay, kann man. Was sucht
da drin? Cache.
Ah. Habe ich noch nie
verwendet. Ich mache immer
als erstes mal ein TMAX auf und such da drin.
Na, über Snap.
Über Snap. Ich brauche
kein Snap für TMAX. Das ist ja lieber aus
dem Paket. Aus den Repos
und gut ist. Ja, die kommen aus Südafrika.
Hehehe.
Mal sie testen BigMAX, wir analysieren
Fonts. Ich finde es gar nicht so unwichtig,
dass da der Standard-Font ordentlich ist.
Weil das eine Sache ist, wo
Ubuntu gerade auf dem Desktop lange Zeit
total
gekrankt hat.
Also der Standard-Font-Rendering war
absolut grausam früher.
Mittlerweile geht es.
Aber das Standard war so
grottenschlecht früher.
Das konntest du keinem zeigen.
Das sieht Windows ohne
True...
Clear-Font heißt es.
Viel besser aus.
Das sah absolut eklig aus früher.
Und viele Distributionen
haben da auch keinen Wert
drauf gelegt und haben gesagt, ja, installiert
doch sonst irgendwelche
Zusatz-Fonts
und ähm...
Wie heißt da? Font...
Wie heißt der Kram unter Linux nochmal?
Font-Config. Genau.
Irgendwelche Custom-Config...
Custom-Font-Config-Patches
und Gedöns.
Jetzt haben sie es
zumindest langsam gecheckt, dass auch in einem
Default-Zustand
ein
Text nicht
pixelig aussehen sollte.
Kennst du zufällig den IBM
Plex Bono? Ich habe mir
letztens zwei Fonts angeguckt. Und zwar
habe ich mir einmal, ich glaube das war von IBM,
das kann sogar sein, dass das der war,
oder andere, die haben jetzt
bei die, die ähm...
JetBrains
hat jetzt auch einen eigenen Font.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr den schon gesehen habt. Den können wir uns
mal angucken, wie der hier gerendert wird
unter Ubuntu. JetBrains Mono haben die
jetzt auch. Ne, den habe ich mir
noch nicht angeguckt.
Was zeichnet das deiner Meinung nach aus?
Nö, kenne ich nicht.
Für was ist der gut geeignet?
Der Font? Das neue Eclipse
mal gesehen. Welches?
Dieses Taya, Tia,
oder wie das heißt?
Oder was meinst du?
Das ist doch kein neues Eclipse,
das ist doch so eine Cloud IDE Geschichte
von Eclipse. Also das soll doch
glaube ich kein Ersatz
für normale Desktop Eclipse sein.
Bester, Steiner hat gesagt,
bester Mono Space Font, Phyra Mono Medium.
Bester Mono
Space Font, ist immer noch.
Heck, da geht nichts drüber.
Weder Source Code Pro,
noch irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Heck
ist der beste Font, den es gibt.
Also.
Highly, also
extrem subjektiv.
Das ist wirklich
Geschmackssache.
So, und der ist jetzt auch neu.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
nachdem JetBrains ja viele Anhänger hat,
was Programmier IDEs
und sonst was gehen.
Was Programmier IDEs
und sowas angeht, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass viele Leute jetzt auch
Mono verwenden.
Ach ja, und das muss ich sagen, unter Windows
Consolas finde ich auch gut.
Und, und, und, und,
ähm, wie heißt das
andere, was die früher hatten?
Consolas und
Lucida
Console ist es, glaube ich, früher, das andere.
Die zwei Microsoft Sachen, muss man
mal zugutehalten, die sind auch ganz okay.
Ein Font, den ich
auch sehr
voll sidetracked wieder arbeite,
muss ich jetzt mal sagen, der alte Mac OS
Default Font.
Den könnte ich mir zwar nicht lange geben im Terminal,
aber ich
finde den sehr schön designt.
Ähm, Mac OS
Old Default Font.
Äh,
Mono Space.
Tja, Monaco? War das Monaco?
Melo?
Monaco war das.
Genau.
Den finde ich echt gut gemacht,
aber den könnte ich mir nicht lange geben
im Terminal.
Ja, den da. Der ist mir
ein bisschen zu schnörkelig.
Ja, der ist mir ein bisschen zu schnörkelig.
Aber ich finde den extrem hübsch, den Font.
Also, das ist auch wohl aus
einer Zeit, wo Apple ordentliche
Sachen designen konnte.
Ähm, ich finde den sehr hübsch, den Font.
Also, eines der hübschesten Fonts, den es
gibt, finde ich, den alten Mac OS
ähm,
Default Font.
Aber ich könnte ihn mir nicht lange geben im Terminal.
Windings.
Naja, das hat jetzt aber,
ich bin eigentlich gesagt, ich würde es angucken wollen, gar nichts zu tun.
Ähm, okay,
also mit Windows-Taste macht man nicht das
Startmenü auf.
Wo ist überhaupt das Startmenü?
Hier unten?
Alt-Escape war es früher, ne.
Ui, was macht ein Alt-Escape?
Was mache ich da gerade?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was ich da mache.
Ähm, also Windows-Taste
macht jetzt so ein Exposé-View.
Das finde ich nice.
Das macht es aber schon eine ganze Weile, das ist nichts Neues.
Man muss jetzt sagen,
seitdem die ihr Custom Desktop
aufgegeben haben, gefällt mir Ubuntu Desktop
deutlich besser wieder.
Ich verwende es nicht, ich bin mittlerweile bei einer anderen
Distribution im Desktop gelandet.
Ähm, aber
allemal besser als Unity.
Was ist eigentlich ein typischer
Hacker-Font?
So ein, so ein
Terminus. Terminus ist
ein richtig
Terminus ist so ein richtiger Hacker-Font.
Ja. Ne.
Ist doch nicht Terminus.
Terminus.
Was ist so ein richtiger Hacker-Font?
Das da. Ne.
Oder? Ist das Terminus?
Keine Ahnung, ob es Terminus ist.
Gibt es da nicht mal ein gescheites
Beispiel für,
wenn die offizielle Font-Seite noch nicht mal
den eigenen Font verwendet?
Wir installieren das jetzt einfach mal und ich zeige euch Terminus.
Das ist der Hacker-Font
schlechthin, finde ich.
Terminus
haben wir nicht installiert, okay.
Uptsearch.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das noch drin ist.
Hier.
Ich kann ja nicht mehr tippen.
Install. Terminus.
Ne, wie heißt?
X-Fonts. Was?
X-Fonts. Terminus.
Was beknackter Name.
Ne.
Fonts. Terminus.
Warum gibt es
X-Fonts. Terminus und Terminus
und Paketbenahmung
auf Doom wieder?
Das gerade könnte wirklich
Pokémon sein, ja.
Ja.
Das ist aber alles mögliche.
So. Custom Font.
Terminus. Pass auf, jetzt wird es hässlich.
Damn. Terminus.
Das ist der
Hacksaw-Font, Leute.
Und jetzt können wir noch einstellen.
Colors.
Gibt es noch Grün?
Gibt es noch Grün? Gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gibt nur noch
Crayon Black. Green on Black.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
Hacker-Font.
So.
Jetzt sind wir
jetzt Hacker-Man.
Huge.
Jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Upgraded.
Wie hieß da noch mal dieses
das da?
Wie hieß
Wie hießen das noch mal?
Das müssen wir jetzt.
Es hieß einfach Hollywood.
Das brauchen wir.
Achtung.
Matrix. Wir machen das viel besser.
Viel besser. Matrix ist out.
Vielleicht.
Wir machen mal zum
Einstimmen. Zum Einstimmen haben wir noch mal 10 Matrix.
Aber das
geht viel besser.
Oh, ich sogar.
Das geht
besser.
Big X The 1.
Abonniert. 2 Monate. Dankeschön.
Huge Sub. Mal kurz schauen, dass ich keine
Subs vergessen habe.
Eigentlich ist es Askiquarium.
Nein. Fuck.
Ich habe nichts vergessen zum Glück.
Aber jetzt passt mal auf.
Hollywood. Jetzt. Jetzt.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Im Hacker. Im Hacker-Look.
Ah, yes.
Excellent. So muss
das sein.
Report a
Problem. Ubuntu is ready.
Jetzt glaube ich nicht, dass Ubuntu ready ist
für den Kram, der hier gerade läuft.
Du musst das Programm Hollywood installieren.
Dann hast du das auch.
So.
Wie macht man das jetzt wieder aus?
Wow. Fuck.
Okay. Geht doch sicher
auch unter Windows. Ne. Das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht unter Windows gehen.
Was? Irgendwas
has stopped.
Weil Hollywood faket nicht. Hollywood
führt echte Programme aus und faket
damit Sachen. Also der führt wirklich
da oben
ein Filesystem LS aus
und irgendwas. Also der führt
wirklich Dinge aus.
Also die machen zwar nix, aber
die führt da wirklich aus.
Ähm.
Na gut. Du könnt
doch. Du könntest den WSL 2 natürlich
laufen lassen. Raus da.
So. Genug
Hacker-Font. Ich mach mal mein Terminal
wieder normal. Ähm.
Text. Gut.
Das wichtigste habe ich jetzt
noch gar nicht geguckt.
Haben die denn Hack als Font?
Nicht kack.
Hack. Hack-Font.
Font-Hack.
Es gibt einmal Hack
als TTF und einmal Hack
als OTF.
Ich muss euch ehrlich gestehen, ich habe bis heute
nicht verstanden genau,
was der Unterschied ist zwischen
TTF und OTF.
Ist das das gleiche, nur
ein anderes Format ist zu speichern?
Ist das in Hollywood
eine TMAX-Session? Es verwendet glaube ich
nicht TMAX, es verwendet irgendeinen anderen
Terminal-Multiplexer, Terminal-
Terminal-Window-Manager oder wie
auch immer man es nennen mag, aber sowas
ähnliches. Ja, hat irgendjemand
eine Ahnung von euch, was der Unterschied ist zwischen TTF und OTF
ist bei Fonts?
OTF ist der offene Standard, TTF ist
True-Type-Microsoft-Zeug.
Ja, Font ist da gleich, okay.
Aber eigentlich ist es doch egal, was ich installiere,
solange mein Font-Render
gedönst ist, versteht und
ähm, wahrscheinlich
versteht das alles Install.
Also ich brauche
einen ordentlichen Terminal-Font.
Wobei der Default-Mono-Space nicht
schlecht ist von Ubuntu.
Den fand ich schon immer recht hübsch.
Hack.
Ah, yes.
So
gefällt mir das Terminal schon viel besser.
Endlich ein ordentlicher
Font.
Exquisite, excellent Font.
Wisst ihr,
da muss ich jetzt mal loswerden, was
für mich schwierig ist im Home-Office,
muss ich grad mal loswerden.
Eine Sache, die für mich schwierig ist im Home-Office
und zwar,
ich mein, ich hab kein,
ich hab online jetzt nicht irgendwie
so die, so die
Ultra-Fake-Personalität, wie das
äh, manche quasi fast schon
schauspielermäßig machen, ja.
Also ich mein, ich bin zu 90% online
so, wie ich offline auch bin, aber
ich reiß mich offline
mehr zusammen, was dummes Geschwätze
angeht oder irgendwie
Twitch-Memes oder irgendwelche
Pepe-Emotes
und Zeug, also
da reiß ich mich offline immer ein bisschen mehr zusammen
und das geht recht einfach, weil
ich halt offline bin. Ja, also
ich bin, ich bin RL irgendwo
und da kann ich mir ganz gut merken
so, okay, jetzt sind wir im
Real-Life-Modus.
Das fällt mir im Home-Office ein bisschen schwer.
Ich merk schon,
dass ich immer unkontrollierter
anfange, ähm,
Emotes und Sachen
in Teams zu pasten.
Ich hab heute beispielsweise
schon, schon fast
also ohne nachzudenken
PepeHands in Chat
gepostet.
Auf der Arbeit.
Lustigerweise, einer hat's anscheinend verstanden,
weil der hat's gleich geliked.
Also erstmal ne Runde PepeHands reingepostet.
Das ist
halt schwierig, weil wenn man im Home-Office sitzt,
da ist kein, da ist überhaupt kein
Unterschied, weißt du? Du sitzt vorm gleichen Rechner
mit der gleichen Hardware, gleiche
Tastatur, gleiche Maus, gleicher Bildschirm.
Sieht genauso aus.
Bloß, dass du jetzt ja eigentlich arbeiten musst.
Es ist aber nicht schlimm. Man muss ja
sagen, bei uns sind die meisten Leute jetzt ja
technikaffin.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
die können vielleicht nicht direkt was mit
anfangen, aber die, die haben da auch keine
Probleme mit, wenn die Leute ein bisschen rumspinnen.
Außer vielleicht, wenn jetzt einer
irgendeine, irgendeine
Führungsdings-Präsentation halten soll und wird
da PepeHands reinmachen. Da wird man vielleicht ein bisschen
doof gucken, aber
wahrscheinlich würde das sogar durchgehen,
weil die sich dann da sagen würden, na gut,
die IT-Leute, die haben sie eh nicht mehr alle.
Da müssen wir nichts drauf
geben.
Ich sag manchmal mittlerweile
schon excellent vor mich hin.
So nach dem Motto, ah, yes, excellent.
Das ist so eine richtig doofe
Angewohnheit, excellent zu sagen in letzter Zeit.
Ah, yes,
excellent. Warum hat Ubuntu
laufend Fehler?
Application C
CZE. Was ist denn das
überhaupt? Bringt Farbe
in die Log-Files.
Kackt eher ab, anstatt
Nee, das ist irgendwas anderes, oder?
Ubuntu.
Okay, es kackt anscheinend ab.
Wie hast du das gerade gemacht,
die Größe von dem Fenster zu verändern während
mittlere Maustaste? Du hältst
die Windows-Taste
oder deine Meta-Taste gedrückt und
machst mit der mittleren Maustaste, kannst du
Du musst nicht immer an den Rand
gehen, da flippt man aus, wenn man am Rand
ist. Immer am Rand.
Ich muss mich da ein bisschen umgewöhnen,
weil ich Track & Drop die Fenster
bei mir normalerweise mit
Meta-Rechtsklick, das geht unter Ubuntu
nicht. Bei welcher Firma arbeitest
du denn, dass du im Home-Office bist? Also bei welcher
sag ich nicht genau, aber es ist eine Bank in Frankfurt.
Da gibt's ja nicht so wenige,
die da in Frage kommen in Frankfurt.
Achso, wir wollten uns das ZFS-Zeug
noch ein bisschen angucken.
Was list?
Gibt nur zwei Banken in Frankfurt. So,
so sieht's aus.
Revealed. Also wir haben zwei
ZFS-Pools, die...
Ah, okay.
Wir haben 2 GB fürs Boot
für Boot und
55 GB für den Rest.
Eine Sache muss man sich nämlich
merken, wenn man ZFS verwendet,
ist es manchmal
nicht so ganz klar,
wenn man
DF macht
für den Speicherplatz
zu dem... Ach, wie ging das andere
noch mal was? ZFS-List?
Ah, ZFS-List war das andere, genau.
Ähm...
Da ist es manchmal nicht so ganz
klar, ob das stimmt, was
in DF-H steht.
Man sollte lieber mit ZFS-List gucken.
Da ist es auf jeden Fall genau.
Ubuntu
Afklo. Nee,
Afko. Alles klar.
Beste.
Ist das random oder ist das irgendein südafrikanisches
ähm...
südafrikanisches Wort?
Afko.
Ich will sagen, es liest sich wirklich wie
Afklo.
Schreibt mal Tree ins Terminal.
Onu? Du meinst,
weil's Color ist? Not impressed.
Wenn man ein bisschen mehr Hacker
aussehen will, äh, Hacker sein will,
dann kann man wenigstens mal sowas machen.
Ähm...
Oh, das Scrollen funktioniert nicht,
weil ich keine T-Marks konfiguriere.
Gut, also,
funktioniert wohl recht gut, dass man
das Ganze mit ZFS installiert.
Ähm, wie ist denn so die Aufteilung
hier?
Also erstmal gucken, was die aktiviert haben.
Zpool.
Was gab's noch? Status
gab's noch, ne?
Genau, keine Fehler.
Alles
online. Natürlich alles nur auf einer
Disk.
Zpool, was? Zpool,
Zpool...
Ist doch viel wichtiger, haben wir Auto
vervollständigt für ZFS? Ne.
Das haben wir natürlich nicht.
Iostat gibt es aber.
Ja, wir sehen, dass er gerade nichts
macht. Ähm...
Wie haben sie denn das so eingeteilt?
Für meinen
Geschmack ein bisschen viel, ehrlich gesagt.
Was default ist.
Man muss ja nicht alles irgendwie
in ein eigenes Dataset hängen.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen übertrieben.
Also, wir haben einmal
Pool für Boot, okay.
Das haben wir ja vorher schon erfahren.
Das ist, weil Krupp wohl irgendwie Probleme
hat, das zu booten.
Wobei ich mich wundere, dass
Krupp Probleme hat, das zu booten.
Wir haben
doch schon vor
drei Jahren oder so mal
oder vor zwei Jahren im Stream
nen
ZFS-Root-Partition
gebootet. Also Krupp,
ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass Krupp das kann.
Aber vielleicht haben die andere Probleme.
Hm, weiß nicht.
So, also
wie haben die das eingerichtet? Wir haben einen extra
Pool für Boot.
Dann haben wir einen Pool
für den Rest.
So, Airpool ist auch so mit der, so ein bisschen der, der
Default-Name. Oder
Tank. Die Solaris-Leute
nennen das Ding immer Tank.
Bob builds
an Army.
Gegen Google+.
Tank haben die Solaris-Leute immer.
Ähm...
Wir haben einen zweiten Pool.
Da haben wir einmal nen Root-Data-Set drauf
und nen User-Data-Data-Set.
Find ich
eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Find ich eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Das hier ist mir ein bisschen viel, ehrlich
gesagt. Das muss man nicht alles auf
ZFS. Da muss man nicht einzelne
Mountpoints und Geschiss machen.
Also man kann's auch übertreiben.
Log, Log ist ganz
sinnvoll als eigenes zu machen, weil
wenn man Snapshots macht und rollt
was zurück, will man ja vielleicht die Logs noch behalten, um
zu gucken, was ist denn schief gelaufen, weshalb man
zurückgerollt hat. Aber den Rest
könnte man eigentlich mehr oder weniger
ins Gleiche
stecken.
Naja, was auch immer. Aber funktioniert
gut.
Dürfte eine der ersten Distributionen
sein,
die ZFS im Installer drin haben.
Ich glaub, es gibt noch eins, zwei andere, aber viele gibt's
nicht. So.
Also, was gibt's sonst noch Neues?
Ähm...
Jetzt fällt mir auf den ersten Blick, sieht man jetzt...
sieht es relativ normal aus.
Kann man noch
komplett Dark Theme einstellen?
Ah, yes. Sehr schön.
Das finde ich gut, dass das mittlerweile
funktioniert, weil ich bilde mir ein,
das ging früher auch nicht richtig.
Ähm...
Also man kann komplett Dark
Theme machen, das finde ich schon mal gut.
So, das Dock kann man unten
für die Windows-Fans rechts
da... ich kenn niemanden, der
sein Dock rechts hat oder links verwenden.
Wenn du zu... was?
Verwendest du zufällig die
ZFS-Intent-Log-Funktionalität für...
Nö. Kennst... Nee, verwende ich nicht.
Ich hab mein ZFS
relativ Default.
Das einzige, was ich gemacht hab, ist geguckt, dass das
von den Blockgrößen passt.
Und Kompression angemacht.
So. Gibt's sonst noch was Neues?
Nachdem ich zu faul bin, jetzt alles zu
durchsuchen. Wir gucken mal, ob es eine...
Punkt 4...
Oh Leute, mir fällt gerade ein.
20.04.
Die Version ist, äh, problematisch.
Wisst ihr auch warum?
Wer hatte am
20.04. Geburtstag?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt falsch liege.
Wer hatte Geburtstag am 20.04., Leute?
Das, ähm...
Die Version, die ist, äh,
kritisch. Ja, Sebarro
hat Recht.
Ein Österreicher, korrekt.
Ähm...
Allerdings interessiert dir das in Südafrika
wahrscheinlich wenig. Wir hätten wahrscheinlich
in Deutschland 20.4 übersprungen, oder so.
Bei
solchen, da tun wir uns mit
komplett, so komplett unrelated
Sachen, tun wir uns ja sehr schwer.
Hat damit ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts
zu tun. Aber ich glaube, wir hätten, wir hätten echt
ein Problem damit gehabt, wenn das Ding 20.4 hieß.
Ähm...
Ach so, Sebarro. Ich dachte, du hättest das so
gewusst. Ich hab gedacht hier...
Die 5 Monate
SAP, SAP, ne, nicht die 5 Monate
SAP, die 50 Mon... 9 Monate SAP,
die du bist, hab ich gerade, hätten schon zu so hohem
EQ geführt, dass du das weißt.
Hatte leider Encryption für
ZFS getestet, als es noch
äh... Plus of Master war.
Aber noch nicht
released. Nach einem
äh...
Was?
Was ist denn? Ein Fupa?
Ach so, ne, ah!
Small Brain hatte ich gerade.
Ähm... Hat sich
der Pool komplett verabschiedet und ist wohl einmal
über die Meta dann drübergekommen. Das ist schlecht.
Wir hatten es ausprobiert. Wir hatten es vor 2 Jahren
oder so mal ausprobiert. Ich glaube, auch
im Stream. Ist schon ewig her. War
einer der ersten Streams, die ich damals
gemacht hab. Ist schon ne ganze Weile her.
Da hatten wir nen Ubuntu installiert mit
äh... ZFS auf verschlüsseltem...
auf verschlüsseltem
Root. Und dann
haben wir sogar noch eingerichtet per
SSH-Unlocken. Das war
nen Ack. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Ich glaub, da haben wir 6 Stunden
dran gesessen, bis der Scheiß funktioniert hat.
Damals, wie gesagt,
vor 2 Jahren, das war noch, das war noch
hochgradig Alpha, der ganze, der ganze Mist.
Ja? Ich weiß noch, wir haben, wir haben
installiert, ZFS, Ubuntu
on Root, encrypted
und dann, dass man beim Booten
unlocken konnte über SSH.
Das war nen Ack.
Das ist mir im Gedächtnis geblieben.
Also suchen wir mal.
20.4 Features.
Was gibt's für neue Features?
OMG Ubuntu UK.
Aha. So.
Aha, das ist ein Fosserl.
Fosserl. Fosserl.
Ich weiß...
Zu was für ner Kategorie
Tier gehört das?
Ich hab erst gedacht, es könnte ne Katze sein, aber
dafür sieht sie irgendwie nicht katzig
genug aus. Was ist denn
ein Fosser? Frettkatze.
Raubtierart.
Das ist so ein Zwischending zwischen
Otter und Katze, oder?
Katzenartige. Okay, es ist ne Katze.
Es sieht halt echt aus
wie so ne Mischung aus Otter und Katze.
Quasi ein, ein Grotter.
Nix, oh, Twitch hat grad Probleme
mit, äh, mit dem Chat.
Wobei ich nicht
sicher bin, ob Twitch Probleme hat, oder
mal wieder Provider in Deutschland Probleme
mit dem Chat haben, oder beide.
Die Telekom hat, äh, ja, hab ich auch
lustigerweise funktioniert
das mal mit Vodafone. Ansonsten,
ansonsten ist Vodafone ja eher
hier, die da. Also ich
wäre lieber bei der Telekom, wenn ich dort das gleiche
an Bandbreite kriegen würde, wie bei Vodafone.
Was ich für Probleme hatte schon hier
mit, mit Framedrops und alles, das hatte ich
bei der Telekom nie.
Und ich hatte lange Zeit zwei Anschlüsse
parallel, dass, wenn
es abgekackt ist, ich einfach
umschalten konnte, aber das war mir irgendwann zu teuer
und ich hab's nicht mal eingesehen, dass ich doppelt
bezahlen soll, weil wir es in Deutschland nicht
geschissen kriegen, unsere Infrastruktur ordentlich
auszubauen. Angeblich ein
europäisches Routingproblem. Also
wenn's ein europäisches Routingproblem wäre, wäre
Vodafone garantiert auch davon betroffen, weil
Vodafone ist ja von allen Routingproblemen
und mehr betroffen,
wenn es die gibt. Also man
kann davon ausgehen, wenn man gucken will, ob es
ein internationales Problem ist,
guckt man erst mal, ob Vodafone auch betroffen ist.
Wenn Vodafone auch betroffen ist, dann war's okay.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Problem.
Kann natürlich immer noch ein reines Vodafone-Problem
sein. Du könntest jetzt
MP-TCP,
Multipass-TCP oder was ist das?
Das ging doch mit Samba schon lange.
Oder war das was anderes?
Nee, ist anscheinend was anderes.
Multipass-TCP.
Ich weiß, dass man mit Samba schon mehrere
Netzwerkkarten verwenden konnte.
Der Kelmore schreibt,
Vodafone meinte heute zu mir, dass LTE in meiner Stadt
komplett überlastet ist.
Krieg auch laufend Verbindungsabbrüche.
Vodafone
meint echt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ich hatte es euch ja mal erzählt, aber zur
Erheiterung für alle, die
nicht dabei waren.
Ich hab mich ja jetzt schon ein paar mal beschwert bei Vodafone,
weil hier im Stream, zeig's euch ja mal.
Heute ist ja, heute ist ziemlich gut.
Guck mal Leute, 0 Dropped Frames.
Das hatten wir noch nie.
Ohne Scheiß. Das hatten wir, das...
hatten wir noch nie.
Dass 0 Frames gedroppt waren.
Zumindest, ich hab mich ja öfters mal bei Vodafone ausgekotzt,
wie schlecht das Ganze ist.
Alle über den Twitter-Support,
weil der Twitter-Support antwortet immer schön.
Also, da muss man echt sagen, hier,
easy clap.
Twitter-Support macht seinen Job gut, Vodafone an sich
macht seinen Job nicht gut.
Die leiten einen dann immer an den Techniker
weiter, bla bla bla.
Und da hat mich, wo ich grad beim Mexikaner
der Haftbefehl Mexikaner,
Leute, die ich öfters sah, weil die wissen, was der
wer der Haftbefehl Mexikaner ist,
hab ich grad beim Haftbefehl Mexikaner
gesessen.
Und da hat mich der Vodafone-Techniker angerufen.
Und der Chat
spoilert schon wieder.
Und nach langer Rede kurzer Sinn,
ähm, der hat mir erst versucht zu erklären,
was Sache ist. Er hat überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben.
Und am Ende wahrscheinlich meinte,
wahrscheinlich, weil ihm sonst nichts mehr
eingefallen ist, meinte er,
das liegt daran, weil
mein 2,4 GHz WLAN
und mein 5 GHz WLAN die gleiche SSID
haben. Deswegen hätte das
ähm, Kabelmodem Fehler.
Ich wusste nicht mal, was
ich sagen soll.
Mir ist legit nichts eingefallen.
Das ergibt so wenig Sinn,
dass mir da irgendwie wirklich nichts eingefallen.
Ich hab, ich hab nur was
gesagt in der Richtung so, aha,
leuchtet mir technisch zwar jetzt überhaupt nicht ein,
aber meinetwegen.
Ja, WLAN SSIDs. Vor allem
wisst ihr, was der Witz ist?
Ich verwende noch nicht mal
das eingebaute WLAN im
äh, nicht Speedport,
wie heißt das bei Vodafone?
Oh, wie heißt die scheiß Box von
Vodafone nochmal? Connect Box.
Dass die auch alles,
dass die den Kram nicht irgendwie mal griffig nennen
können. Connect Box.
Ich verwende ja noch nicht mal das, das WLAN
in der Connect Box. Ich hab meine eigenen
Access Points, die wahrscheinlich
dreimal so viel kosten wie so ne kack Connect Box.
Ähm, und
verwende null von Vodafone. Gar nichts.
Das einzige, was ich von Vodafone verwende,
von dieser Connect Box, ist wirklich das
Kabelmodem, was drin ist. Also
das Ding als Kabelmodem.
Und, und dann notgedrungen als Router.
Ja, Router Schrägstich Kabelmodem.
Ich verwende nichts davon.
Nichts. Äh, auch das WLAN nicht.
Und da wollte er mir wirklich erzählen,
es liegt daran, dass ich an meinen Access Points,
nicht an den Unity Media Access Points, das hätte ich ja noch
irgendwie verstanden, wenn das Ding,
keine Ahnung, zu viel RAM braucht
oder sonst was, ja. Also an
meinen Access Points, ähm,
die SSID doppelt
eingestellt sind und deswegen das Kabelmodem Fehler wirft.
Das hab, da hab ich echt am
Verstand der, der Menschheit wieder gezweifelt.
Connect Box ist Unity Media.
Ja, ich hab ja auch noch Unity Media, aber
jetzt ist Unity Media. Ja, Vodafone.
Benutzt eigentlich irgendwer ein eigenes
Modem? Kann das irgendwelche Vorteile haben?
Naja, ähm,
wenn du es besonders, äh,
roh haben willst, ja,
also sprich, wenn du es besonders,
besonders direkt und viel selbst machen willst, kann das schon seine
Vorteile haben. Du, du hast zum Beispiel
kein doppeltes NAT mehr.
Oder besser gesagt,
du kannst doppeltes NAT
vermeiden, ja. Also,
du hast ja normalerweise,
dann auf Provider Seite,
hast du dein, ähm, wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus,
du hast einen richtigen, echten,
äh, Dual Stack mit vollwertigem
IPv4 und IPv6, ansonsten hättest du ja
quasi Triple NAT, ähm,
dann machst du einmal NAT
am Ausgang auf IPv4
an deinem, äh,
an deiner Connect Box und,
einmal wahrscheinlich NAT an deinem,
an deiner Fritzbox
oder anderen Router, den du dahinter hängen hast.
Doppeltes
NAT ist nicht so schön, vor allem wenn man
Ports weiterleiten will, nicht.
Da kann sich das schon lohnen.
Wenn du Dual Stack Lite hast,
kannst du es eh vergessen mit Port weiterleiten,
weil das funktioniert rein technisch gesehen
nicht.
IPv4, mit IPv6 hast du das Problem
nicht, da gibt's genug Adressen. Äh,
Nixor schreibt, gestern war ein Vodafone
Techniker bei uns im Büro,
sah aus wie ein Montana Black
Verschnitt. Meint
FIFA 22 Pro zu sein, sagt Vodafone
ist beste. Ja, ganz
bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Glaub ich dir sofort.
Äh, warum würde man eine
Connect Box und eine Fritzbox verwenden?
Zum Beispiel,
wenn man mehr, wenn man die Funktionen
einer Fritzbox verwenden will,
die eine
Connect Box nicht hat.
Oder aber, wenn man
einen,
wenn man VoIP verwenden will,
nicht von Unity Media oder
nicht von Vodafone, so hab ich's zum Beispiel
bei mir daheim, ich verwende
obwohl, obwohl mein
Vodafone Anschluss VoIP
bietet, verwende
ich Voice over IP, also Telefon
von nem anderen Anbieter.
Ganz einfach aus dem Grund,
weil ich keinen Bock mehr habe auf Festnetznummer
Portierung.
Warum dann nicht direkt die Fritzbox?
Kannste auch
machen. Kannste auch machen.
Natürlich, warum nicht? Kannste auch machen.
Musst bei Vodafone anrufen und sagen,
hey, ähm, ich will meinen eigenen
Router verwenden, ich will mein eigenes Modem verwenden,
macht mal.
Kannste auch machen.
Ähm, ja stimmt, wo bin ich, stimmt, genau, ich verwende hier auch
äh, ich verwende hier auch
äh, nicht das
Voice over IP von Unity Media und zwar bin ich
bei Easybell
und hab den billigsten, den
billigsten Tarif, den's da gibt.
Hier, Internet und Telefon,
ich brauch Telefon.
Naja, wo ist
dann nur Telefon? Wo ist dann Telefon?
Ich brauch nur, ich brauch nur Telefon.
Wo ist es denn? Ach nee, Privatkonten, ich bin bei Geschäftskonten.
Telefon, ja.
2,99 im Monat.
Und der
Vorteil davon ist,
Eatspell, genau.
Easy.
Du bist bei ZipGate. Ne, bei ZipGate bin
ich, bin ich bei ZipGate.
Hatte ich mal in Erwägung gezogen, ich weiß gar nicht,
warum ich gesagt hab, ähm,
ich nehm Easybell, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Vielleicht, weil das Portierungsformular klarer war,
ich weiß es nicht mehr, hat kein, hat glaub ich keinen
großartigen, äh, weiteren, weiteren Sinn
gehabt. Ich vermute mal, bei euch
kostet es ähnlich viel.
Macht, macht wahrscheinlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Zumindest hat's den riesen Vorteil
dadurch, dass ich jetzt
im Endeffekt nur noch Fernseh und
Internet über Vodafone verwende,
dass, wenn ich mal wieder wechseln
will zur Telekom, ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Da muss ich keine Festnetznummer portieren,
weil das Portieren der Festnetznummer
war immer das ätzendste überhaupt.
So, aber wir wollten ja mal gucken,
was es hier noch Neues im aktuellen
Ubuntu gibt. Ja, aber
VDSL funktioniert das.
Wir reden ja vom Kabelmodem.
Ähm, Kabelmodem, wenn man, wenn man
eine eigene Fritzbox mit Kabelmodem verwenden
will, sieht das anders aus. Da müssen die
dich irgendwie freischalten.
Ich vermute mal, die müssen in ihr,
was auch immer dahinter ist,
ich kenn mich mit Kabeltechnik nicht aus,
äh, wahrscheinlich die MAC von deinem
Modem oder irgendeine Unic-ID
von deinem Modem eintragen, dass du
überhaupt zugreifen darfst von dort.
Weil so ne,
so ne klassische Authentifizierung
machen die ja gar nicht mehr.
Also bei, bei DSL
hast du ja noch so ein richtiges
Authentifizierungsverfahren
mit Username und Nummer und bei Kabel
ist es einfach nur,
aha, das Gerät kenn ich,
den Anschluss kenn ich, der darf.
Wie gesagt, dieses Gerät
an diesem Anschluss. Das ist
deutlich simpler. Und die müssen es dann freischalten
und dann kannst du deine eigene Fritzbox verwenden.
So. Was halt übelst
nice ist, wenn es hier, äh, bei
Ubuntu LTS-Releases geht,
dass
die mindestens 5 Jahre supported sind.
Wie gesagt, 14.04 ist immer
noch supported, das muss man sich mal
vorstellen. Mittlerweile, ich glaube
früher waren es 8 Jahre, jetzt sind es 5 Jahre, aber 14.04
8 Jahre
ist übelst geil, oder?
Ist das nicht richtig unsafe?
Sagt es so.
Was meinst du, dass die keine, äh, dass die
keine, ähm,
dass die keinen Benutzernamen verwenden und so?
Nö, ich glaube, ich glaube
nicht, dass das großartig unsafe ist. Ich meine,
das muss ja diese Mac
an diesem Anschluss sein, dass es funktioniert.
Warum sollte man auch
14.04 verwenden? Zum Beispiel,
wenn man bei meinem kack, äh,
kack, ähm,
VM war, äh, VM
Hoster ist. Ich habe euch ja
erzählt, ich habe eine Lifetime-VM gekauft.
Vor 5 Jahren
oder so. 35 Dollar
Lifetime-VM.
Also einmal 35 Dollar
bezahlt für immer eine VM haben.
Und dieser Anbieter, der
ist mehr down als up. Das ist der, der
beschissenste Anbieter aller Zeiten.
Der bietet nur 14.04 an.
Als Installation.
Man kann
natürlich trotzdem selbst, selbst
dann, äh, 18.04
oder 20.04 installieren.
Der hat mit diesem Deal bestimmt richtig Minus gemacht.
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus.
Das haben, glaube ich, viel mehr gemacht, als er wollte.
Ich bin
ja da auch nur drauf gekommen, weil mich
einer auf der Arbeit darauf hingewiesen hat und hat gesagt,
hier, guck mal, hast du gesehen?
Ähm, und der hat sich da schon
5 Kisten wahrscheinlich geholt.
Habe ich mir auch mal eine geholt.
Auf zu Contabo. Nee, nee,
mit dieser Billig-VM wechsel ich nicht.
Diese Billig-VM verwende ich ja auch für nix.
Was irgendwie relevant, relevant ist.
Diese Billig-VM verwende
ich einzig und allein nur,
wenn ich mal irgendwo eine Public IPv4-Adresse
brauche für irgendwelche SSH-Tunnel
oder sowas. Man hat sagenhafte
2 MB die Sekunde lesen, schreiben
bei denen. Einfach vor dem
Haus mal aufgraben und easy
Internet gönnen. Ich glaube, so einfach ist
das nicht. Vor dem Haus aufgraben
und dort mal
nebenbei an so ein Kabel, äh,
da sich dran
stöpseln, ja.
So einfach ist das, denke ich, nicht.
Wenn das nämlich so einfach wäre und dass man
die auch so einfach bescheißen könnte.
Ich meine, irgendjemand muss es ja geben, der einen Vertrag hat,
wo diese MAC draufläuft an diese Adresse.
Dann hätten die das auch
anders gemacht. Glaube nicht, dass
es so einfach ist.
Selbst wenn du ans Kabel drankommst,
du musst dich ja immer noch anstöpseln. Das ist ja nicht so einfach
wie bei irgendeinem
bei irgendeinem Switch, wo du dich dranstöpselst.
Nix, oh, dazu gibt's
auch noch eine schöne Sache. Weil er sagt, ich soll
den Kram doch einfach bei mir daheim laufen lassen.
Ja.
Ein tolles Rack. Wisst ihr, was da dran
zuerst kaputt gegangen ist?
Nicht spoilern, Chat.
Oder besser gesagt, die, die es wissen, nix sagen.
Was meint ihr, was mir zuerst
kaputt gegangen ist? Also, ich hab hier,
ich hab hier unten eine USV, da drüber
hab ich einen Switch, dann hab ich, wo sieht man das denn,
wo sieht man das denn schön?
Ja.
Äh, unten ist eine USV, Stromleiste,
äh, 10 Gigabit Switch,
einen normalen, äh, Switch, äh,
Patchpanel und meine 4 HE Kiste.
Was meint ihr, was mir
als erstes kaputt gegangen ist?
Richtig,
die USV. Das Ding, was
ich habe, dass der Kram mir nicht kaputt
geht.
Die USV ist mir verreckt.
Von vor einem Monat oder so.
Jetzt läuft einfach alles
ohne USV und funktioniert wieder.
Also merke, USV
macht mehr Downtime als keine USV.
Von welchem
Anbieter war die Cyberpower?
Das war eine Cyber
Power
Die da
war das, genau die.
Die da.
Die ist aber nicht, ich, also
die Aussage, die ist kaputt, ist
wahrscheinlich, äh, nicht ganz richtig.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach nur die Batterie
kaputt. Tja, hättest du eine
Ja, da kann natürlich nichts passieren.
Ist klar.
Das könnte dir bei, das könnte dir bei APC genauso passieren.
Das könnte dir bei allen, bei allen Anbietern
passieren können.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die kaputt ist.
Ich glaube einfach, die Batterie ist kaputt.
Oder was heißt kaputt?
Die Batterie ist einfach nach, nach längerer Zeit
jetzt, äh, hinüber.
Welche VM benutzt du jetzt?
Das ist jetzt, das ist das aktuelle
2004 Ubuntu.
Was bei Linus Tech Tipps ist
auch erst die USV abgebrannt.
Mussten ein Loch in den Serverraum machen, um
USV austauschen zu können.
Bei Linus Tech Tipps
Ich glaube nicht, dass die manchmal
die Sachen so schlecht planen,
wie es in den Videos aussieht.
Ich glaube, die machen das absichtlich, dass sie
ein Video drüber machen können.
Genauso wie den Server, woran ein Handstand
drauf machen musste, dass die CPUs richtig
angepresst waren.
Keiner kann so bescheuert sein und wirklich den Kram
so verkaufen wollen und so betreiben.
Das macht man einfach für Show und für Videos.
Die tun ja bei Linus Tech Tipps
Das macht es ja auch irgendwo unterhaltsam.
Die tun ja auch bei Linus Tech Tipps
immer so, als bauen die jetzt
irgendwelche ganz wichtigen Systeme zusammen,
die sie jetzt sofort brauchen oder
verkaufen wollen oder sonst was.
Das sind einfach nur Systeme, die sie wahrscheinlich
für Showzwecke zusammenbauen.
Die brauchen die gar nicht.
Das sind ja auch die einzigen, die
ein Studio haben,
was im Hintergrund aussieht wie
eine Küche. Alle anderen nehmen
vielleicht in ihrer Küche auf und wollen,
dass es aussieht wie ein Studio, aber bei denen ist umgedreht.
Das läuft in
Forever Workstation.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit mehrere 4G
Verbindungen zu bündeln?
Du meinst das Mobilfunk?
Also theoretisch
geht das. Gibt es ein paar
Varianten, aber
das hat
alles seine
Problemchen.
Also was du auf jeden Fall brauchst,
dass es ordentlich funktioniert ist,
du brauchst auf der Gegenseite
was, wo du das terminieren kannst drauf.
Also du kannst natürlich so eine Art
Loadbalancing machen über 4
Verbindungen. Dann bringt
es aber nur was, wenn du mehrere Clients hast.
Also du wirst es nicht
schaffen, ohne dass du eine Gegenseite
hast, wo du quasi
deine virtuelle Verbindung drauf
terminieren kannst, dass du beispielsweise
einen Download machen kannst
und der dann auf einmal die Geschwindigkeit von
4 Verbindungen hat. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Was du machen kannst ist, wenn
du im Internet eine Kiste hast
und bei dir lokal eine Kiste.
Du hast lokal eine Kiste mit
deinen, wie auch immer du sie
angeschlossen hast, deinen 4x4G
Verbindungen oder deine mehrere
4G Verbindungen. Du hast im Internet
eine Kiste, da kannst du das da drüber
tunneln.
Ich frage mich jetzt billig aus dem Kopf,
was man da alles für Zeug für braucht.
Und das kannst
du dann quasi so
zusammenfassen, dass es wie eine
normale Layer 2 Verbindung aussieht
für alles was da drüber geht.
Da musst
du dann noch einstellen,
das ist schon ordentlich kompliziert.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so easy.
So und dann kannst du
nämlich so quasi für die Geräte, die das
verwenden, im Endeffekt
sieht das dann so aus, als ist es halt
eine Verbindung.
Also es ist halt ein Kabel im Endeffekt.
Also es ist ein langes Kabel
dahin.
Das hat aber alles seine Vor- und Nachteile
und ist eklig. Ich habe mal ein Abschlussprojekt
über etwas ähnliches gemacht.
Ich habe eine Layer 2
VPN gebaut, um
Telefone an eine Telefonanlage
anzubinden.
Und das hat da auch eine Backup-Verbindung.
Wohlgemerkt, nicht
beides Active-Active, sondern Backup.
Und das ist nicht ohne.
Und schön ist es
nicht.
Also um es mal so billig zu beantworten,
gehen tut es, ja.
Aber nicht schön.
Ich kann dir, ne, kann ich dir nicht empfehlen.
Hört sich so an, als würde es sich
nicht austeilen. Also richtig
probiert habe ich es noch nicht.
Also was ich noch nie probiert habe ist,
irgendwie mal 3 Internetanschlüsse
versuchen zu bündeln.
Zumindest was alle, ein Problem gibt es
bei allen diesen Techniken, die Anschlüsse
sollten ungefähr gleich schnell sein.
Aber es ist also,
es rentiert sich nicht,
einen 16 Mbit DSL und eine
400 Mbit
Unity Media Leitung zu bündeln.
Aber wenn du quasi 4 mal die
gleiche Technik hast, dann kann das durchaus gehen.
Da muss man sich
aber mal in Ruhe einlesen und verschiedene Tutorials
angucken, was man da
so machen kann. Und es gibt
nicht nur eine Lösung.
So wie das unter Linux immer ist.
Was hältst du von VXLAN?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was VXLAN ist.
WLAN, ja.
Aber was ist VXLAN?
Alter, LAN.
Was ist VXLAN?
Virtual Extensible LAN.
What?
Kann das mal losgehen hier?
Oh, der Dr. Mario
Corona Song hier.
Die dazu dient, die Probleme, die in sehr
großen Umgebungen durch die beschränkte Anzahl
von VLANs auftreten können. Fuck!
Was ist Default VLANs 4096?
Was ist so die normale VLAN, maximale
VLAN Anzahl 4096?
Also ich weiß, dass bei
bei Ubiquiti Switchen
ist mit der normalen Firmware ist bei
256 Schluss.
Und mit der Extended
quasi Firmware geht glaube ich
frag nicht, mehr.
Aber wenn man mit
Okay, also das ist was, wenn man mit
4096 nicht auskommt.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich hatte noch nie mit einem
also Netzwerk
admin-technisch mit einem so
großen System zu tun,
dass 4096
VLANs nicht
gereicht haben. Ich bin aber auch kein
Netzwerkmann.
Ähm,
kenne ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ach, mit VXLAN kann man auch layer 2 tunneln.
Wie gesagt, es gibt nicht nur
eine Lösung. War ja klar.
So, ähm,
also was haben wir noch schönes hier
in Ubuntu drinne? Was können wir uns da
angucken? Äh,
Betafreeze, ja das wissen wir, deswegen probieren wir die
gerade aus. Ähm,
das ganze kommt dann Release,
wann ist Release? Release?
Wann ist Release?
Steht das denn irgendwo?
Irgendwie ist das immer Ende des Monats dann.
Was, oben drüber?
Achso, hier!
23. April, ok.
Also man könnte sogar sagen,
wenn man sich jetzt eine neue Kiste installiert,
die man ein bisschen länger betreiben
will, vielleicht könnte man
das schon mit 20.04
machen. Sofern alles funktioniert, was man
haben will.
Lange dauert es nicht mehr.
Was eigentlich für ein Kernel drauf? Haben wir gar nicht
geguckt. Was ist...
Was zum... What the fuck habe ich
jetzt gemacht? Schauen wir mal.
Was haben wir für ein Kernel drauf?
Einen 5.4,
das ist glaube ich einer,
einer vor dem aktuellen, ne?
Aktuell ist 5.5.
Kernel...
Ne, 5.6 ist gerade RC, 5.6
ist noch nicht raus.
Oder ist 5.6 mittlerweile
raus? Ah, vor 5, ich habe
nichts gesagt. 5.6
ist raus, vor
5 Tagen.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Ach doch,
klar habe ich mitgekriegt, das ist mit
WireGuard mittlerweile drin, ja klar.
Aber ich wusste nicht, dass das schon raus
ist. Da müssen
wir doch gleich mal gucken.
Da müssen wir doch gleich mal gucken,
was unsere
ManjaroVM da so sagt.
Erstmal updaten.
Gibt es da schon den neuen Kernel?
Ne, da gibt es nur RC7.
Ja, ist noch nicht
angekommen. So,
also, was ist das hier?
Was haben wir sonst noch für schöne neue Sachen hier?
Ähm, aktuellen Ubuntu-Trainer.
De,
de, de, de.
LTS-Releases, bla, bla, bla,
bla. You can turn on
Dark Mode. Das haben wir lustigerweise
schon so gefunden. Ja,
okay, das Maskottchen interessiert mich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht die Bohne.
Amazon, der Amazon-Launcher ist weg.
Stimmt!
Amazon ist weg.
Aber wahrscheinlich haben sie damit
kein Geld mehr verdient.
Ja, das ist gut, das Amazon. Das ging mir immer auf den
Sack früher. Stimmt!
Ich habe es mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe es gar nicht vermisst.
Small chain user will appreciate greatly.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ubuntu Software Store is now a snap-based
version.
Das heißt, alles was ich über
die Paketverwaltung installiert habe, ist
jetzt ein Snap?
Oder auch nicht.
Slow calculator loading times.
Jetzt ernsthaft, Linux bzw.
Gnome, ist das wirklich euer
Ernst, dass er fucking calculator
langsam lädt?
Ach, die meinen den UI Store,
die haben wir noch gar nicht angeguckt.
Den da, den hier.
Gnome 34.
So wirklich viel ist da nicht drin.
Was ich persönlich aber sehr
begrüße, dass da nichts großartiges drin ist.
Erstens ist es ein LTS
Release, da müssen die sich die nächsten Jahre drum kümmern.
Und zweitens, wo ich
bei Ubuntu wirklich keinen Bock
drauf habe, ist auf
irgendwelche neuen Ubuntu Einzel-
Aktionen.
Ich meine, wer hat
bitteschön gesagt, ich möchte
meine Netzwerk-Config in einer YAML-Datei
machen? Wer ist
bei Canonical auf die großartige
Idee gekommen und hat Netplan eingeführt?
Das ist, ich
kenne keine andere Distribution, die
den Kram verwendet. Und ich
finde es unglaublich bescheuert,
meine Netzwerk-Config über eine YAML-
Datei editieren zu müssen. Das finde ich
richtig beschissen. Zumal man
ja sagen muss,
man muss es ja gar nicht verwenden.
Aber es wird halt
empfohlen, es ist halt default mittlerweile.
Ich persönlich
muss ja sagen, so als jemand, der
den Kram schon
12,
14 Jahre oder so verwendet,
ähm,
war vorneweg seit 2007,
13, 14, ja, länger noch.
Also, der quasi schon
14, 15 Jahre den Kram verwendet.
Ich
fand ja die
ganz alte
Debian ETC Interfaces
Geschichte, meine persönliche
Meinung, ja, fand
ich die eigentlich am angenehmsten.
Du hattest
stinknormale Config-Dateien, da
konntest du alles konfigurieren an deinem Interface,
inklusive Bridges und irgendwelche
Interface-Optionen
konntest du drin definieren.
Dann hast du gesagt, Interface up.
Und dann hat der alle Config geladen.
Du hast gesagt, Interface down.
Interface war wieder weg.
So, ähm,
das war relativ simpel.
So, da,
mittlerweile hat man ja zig Varianten, wie man das machen kann.
Man kann das über
systemd networkd machen.
Man kann das im Desktop-Bereich mit Network-Manager
machen. Und natürlich auch über DHCP,
aber gut, das ging ja schon immer.
Ähm, und jetzt, und warum
brauche ich dann sowas wie
Netplan mit einer YAML-Config noch oben drauf?
Verstehe ich nicht. Leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Ja, ähm,
mir war nicht X11-Alternative,
mir war, glaube ich, Wayland-Alternative.
Ähm,
ist aber nie aus den
Schuhen gekommen. Allerdings, Wayland
selber ja auch nicht. Ist ja gerade der Witz.
Die kriegen es ja auch nicht gebacken.
Bitte noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Ja.
So, wir wollten uns den
Store angucken. Da ist er.
Warum hat, warum haben die so einen
komischen, so einen
komischen Orangen, weil es Ubuntu ist,
wahrscheinlich. Oh, man kann
Kubernetes können wir installieren.
Das brauchen wir unbedingt bei uns auf dem Desktop.
Wir brauchen unbedingt ein Kubernetes.
Hat mich vorher
im Chat nicht jemand gefragt, wie ich Powerline
finde? Habe ich gar nicht beantwortet,
ne? Müssen wir mal schauen, ob wir das
hier irgendwie drinnen haben.
Ah, ne. Power-Schalter war es,
nicht Powerline. Okay.
Siehste, deswegen ist mein Chat, mein Chat-Logger
ganz gut.
Die Fragen gehen wir gleich durch, wenn wir uns das fertig
angeguckt haben. Ich muss ja heute nicht Punkt
22 ins Bett machen, ist ja frei.
Wartet mal kurz. Was ist?
Ah, die Katz.
Och, Chico, was ist denn los?
Die Katzkratz hat
an der Tür gekratzt. Die wollte unbedingt rein.
Chico, was ist los? Komm mal her.
Komm mal her.
Ja, feine Katze.
Ja.
Und jetzt? Nur mal so, dass ihr ungefähr
eine Vorstellung habt, was gerade hier
sich bei mir auf dem Schrank breitmacht.
Chico, wo habe ich das Bild
von meiner Katze hin? Ja.
So, dass ihr ungefähr eine Vorstellung habt, was sich bei mir gerade
auf dem Schrank breitmacht.
Oder versucht hat. Chico, wo bist
du hin? Ach, da.
Was ist?
Oh, jetzt stellst du
sie hier bei mir unterm Tisch rum.
Zeig Katz-FPS live.
Ne, wie soll ich das, wie soll ich das live zeigen?
Ja, ist ja gut. Gut.
Weiter geht's.
Also das ist jetzt Snap-basiert, oder wie?
Das heißt, wenn ich hier jetzt was installiere,
was können wir denn mal installieren?
Kann man hier drinnen suchen ordentlich?
Komm, wir installieren mal die Arduino IDE.
Mit der mache ich zwar nix,
selbst wenn man Arduino macht,
aber wir können mal gucken, ob das jetzt ein Snap ist oder nicht.
Snap-List.
Tatsächlich.
Aber warum?
Warum ist das jetzt alles
ein Snap? Auf der anderen
Seite ist das nicht schlecht, dass es ein Snap ist,
dann ist es jetzt wenigstens rückstandsfrei
wieder weg. Ist auch okay.
Also finde ich nicht schlimm, dass das
Snap-basiert ist. Das einzige Problem
an einem Snap-basierten
Paketmanager ist, dass es in meinem...
Es gibt halt nicht so wahnsinnig viel als
Snap. Es gibt schon
einige Sachen, aber es ist lange
davon entfernt, wirklich
vollständig zu sein.
Discord können wir als
Snap installieren.
Na gut. Ja, großer
Unterschied.
Ich glaube,
die Standardänderung gibt es anscheinend
ja nicht im aktuellen Ubuntu.
Ich will mir jetzt nochmal schnell den Server-Installer angucken.
Ich wollte mir jetzt nochmal schnell den Server-Installer
angucken, ob sich da irgendwas
geändert hat.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock,
wenn das raus ist,
irgendwann wieder eine Server-Installation
zu machen und festzustellen,
die haben wieder irgendwie...
Das haben die ja schon mal gemacht
vor zwei Versionen oder so,
was ganz merkwürdiges war,
wo du nichts mehr einstellen konntest
und dann musstest du ein anderes ISO runterladen
als bisher, um den normalen Installer
zu kriegen. Schauen wir mal, ob das immer noch
der Fall ist und wenn ja, was für ein ISO wir uns
jetzt runterladen müssen, dass es überhaupt
funktioniert.
Download.
Ubuntu.
Server.
S. CD.
Englisch.
Install.
Mal gucken, ob sie das jetzt hingekriegt haben, ob das jetzt
wieder der Kack-Installer ist
oder ob das jetzt der ordentliche Installer ist,
den man wieder kriegt bei der Server-Installation.
Hat Ubuntu
auch MS Teams?
Da habe ich jetzt leider nicht
geguckt. Aber na gut,
nachdem das Snap-basiert ist, gucken wir
einfach mal. Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
SnapCraft
Store.
Gucken wir mal. Teams.
Sieht nicht so... Doch.
Das ist aber nicht der Office... Gibt es eigentlich einen
offiziellen Teams-Client für Linux?
Ich verwende das immer nur im Browser.
Teams Linux
Download. Gibt es einen offiziellen?
Okay.
Tja, dann gibt es den offiziellen Teams-Client anscheinend
nicht. Es gibt nur
einen inoffiziellen Teams-Client.
Die Frage, die sich mir stellt,
natürlich, wenn es nur einen inoffiziellen
Teams-Client gibt und aber auch einen
offiziellen Teams-Client...
Warum gibt es einen inoffiziellen Client, wenn es
einen offiziellen Client gibt?
Man weiß es nicht.
Oh, das ist ja immer noch der
eklige Installer.
Ich weiß nicht, was die bei...
Was die dort geritten hat
bei diesem Installer.
Das ist vor allem bei Workstation, ist das.
Passt mal auf. Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Das letzte Mal, als die
den normalen Server-Installer zu diesem Installer
geändert haben, konntest du
nichts mehr einstellen. Das war eine absolute
Zumutung. Mal gucken, wie das jetzt ist.
Ob die das noch angepasst haben. Ja, ich weiß.
Es gibt einen Alternativ-Installer.
Das ist auch der einzige, den man verwenden kann, richtig.
Englisch.
Was? Yes.
Installer-Update. Warum nicht?
Subiquity. So.
Layout
German. Warum braucht man
eigentlich zwei Server-Installer? Das habe ich auch nicht
so ganz verstanden.
German. Dann.
Ah, auch gut.
Dann. Dann.
Dann.
Entire-Disk. Jawohl.
Done.
Bios. Ja, ist okay.
Wir haben kein EFI-Boot.
Pick. Keine Ahnung. Hier. Max.
Your server's name.
POG.
Was? Only characters.
Was?
Ah, man kann nicht großschreiben.
Was? Q.
Buntu.
Installer. Was ist das da?
Ich überlege gerade, was hat mir jetzt an dem
Server-Installer mal noch nicht gefallen. Irgendwas hat
mir da das letzte Mal überhaupt gar
nicht dran gefallen. Bis jetzt scheint
es doch ganz, ganz, äh,
okay auszusehen.
Ich meine,
nicht, dass man davon irgendwie großartig jetzt
standardmäßig was bräuchte.
Prometheus könnte man dann mal gucken. Machen wir mal
drauf. Ach, brauchen wir nicht. Wozu? Ist eine Testkiste.
Ähm.
SSH läuft standardmäßig.
Ich weiß,
ich weiß nicht mehr, warum ich so eine
Abneigung gegen diesen Installer hatte.
Der Installer ist identisch mit
18. Ich, ich,
irgendwas hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
an dem Installer, weil ich habe bisher
immer die Alternate-Version runter.
Also irgendwas muss mich so abgeschreckt haben
an dem neuen Installer,
dass ich mir gedacht habe, ne.
Weil der beim Release des Todes
verbuggt war. Ich bilde mir auch ein,
es waren ein paar Sachen nicht drin, die
jetzt gehen. Sowas wie SSH oder so.
Irgendwas. Ich weiß, ich weiß wirklich,
ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Aber irgendwas hat mich so abgefuckt, dass ich
im Kopf habe die ganze Zeit, ich muss den
Internet-Installer verwenden.
Okay, das war es anscheinend.
Reboot.
Pass auf, jetzt geht es nicht.
Was macht der da?
What the fuck?
Erstmal, erstmal ein VPN nach Südafrika aufbauen.
Wann zockst du mal was?
Ich zocke eher
Offstream gerade.
Ähm.
Okay, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich,
warum ich so eine Abneigung gegen
den Ubuntu-Installer hatte.
Moin, Nelly.
Pock.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich da für eine
Abneigung gegen hatte.
Weil bis jetzt hat er eigentlich ganz gut
funktioniert.
Sieht aus wie ein ganz normales,
wie ein ganz normales
Ubuntu-Server.
Jetzt.
Was halt blöd ist, dass
es immer noch diese Netplan-Geschichte ist.
Ich meine,
warum muss ich mein Netzwerk
so konfigurieren? Warum kann ich das nicht ordentlich
konfigurieren?
Da ist Snap drauf. Ja,
das ist auch eine Sache, die mir negativ aufgefallen ist.
Es ist Snap drauf und es ist anscheinend
LXC-standardmäßig mit drauf.
Finde ich auch
überflüssig. Braucht man auch nicht.
Hollywood draufnehmen, müssen wir gleich
nachinstallieren.
Muss sein. Hollywood.
Das ist jetzt richtig Hacker. Hollywood nur über
die Konsole. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt geht.
Hollywood.
Ah, yes.
Excellent. Erstmal eine Runde
Hacker-Man. Wisst ihr was?
Ich habe
mir schon öfters mal überlegt,
was
mache ich
in Videos, wo ich einfach mal
10 Minuten über aktuelle
Technik labere.
Was mache ich da im Hintergrund?
Das, was passiert.
Einfach,
mache ich sowas im Hintergrund? Das ist doch top.
Also nein, es ist nicht top.
Es ist wenn schon hart top.
Aber auch nicht nur.
Weil da mache ich so, da blende ich einfach
sowas ein. Da passiert was im Hintergrund.
Und da blende ich immer
gerade zu dem Thema, was ich labere
passend
die Bilder ein.
Oder das Aquarium oder so.
Sehr schön.
Gut.
Also
es ist ein bisschen viel
Zeugs dabei.
Mit dem neuen Server-Installer.
Ne, das habe ich jetzt nachinstalliert.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Das Battlefield-Video, das kommt dieses Wochenende.
100 pro.
Ich habe jetzt auch wirklich mehr als genug Einsendungen.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr,
was ich für eine Abneigung gegen den
neuen Server-Installer hatte.
Alles in allem
ist okay. Ich meine, dass
da Snap standardmäßig drauf ist,
dass da LXC standardmäßig drauf ist,
braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Ja.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm.
Weil zumindest LXC verwende ich
immer noch ganz gerne, um ein paar Sachen auszuprobieren.
Und
wieder wegzuschmeißen.
Das habe ich eh drauf.
Was ich halt merkwürdig finde, ist, dass sie das jetzt
nicht mal selbst aus den Paketquellen
mitliefern, sondern über Snap installieren.
Am Anfang konnte man keine
festen IPs vergeben. Oh, das könnte es
tatsächlich sein.
Das könnte es tatsächlich sein, dass ich da ein Problem
mit hatte, ja. Weil meine Kisten, also
die Kisten, die halt dauerhaft laufen, die kriegen immer
eine feste IP oder so.
Das mache ich aber mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile kriegen die eine feste DHCP
Reservierung, weil ich zu faul bin, das immer
einzustellen, von Hand.
Ähm, apt install,
das können wir noch machen. Install
docker.io.
Was kriegen wir da für eine Version mit?
Was spricht
eigentlich aktuell gegen CentOS? Nichts.
Gar nichts.
CentOS ist ein super, super
sauberer Betriebssystem.
Mir persönlich gefällt einfach Ubuntu lieber.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir nur CentOS.
Vielleicht mag ich das,
deswegen für meine privaten Kisten Ubuntu.
Weiß nicht.
Was mir an Ubuntu gefällt, ist
so die,
so das Gesamtpaket eigentlich.
Die Paketauswahl ist gut.
Die Server-Minimalinstallation ist ziemlich
minimal. Ich meine, das ist
Debian mit ein bisschen gedönst, ja.
Also die Paketauswahl finde ich
gut, was zur Verfügung steht.
Es steht auch ein bisschen exotischere Sachen zur Verfügung,
wie beispielsweise
ein gescheiter
Bash-Prompt, was ich auch
persönlich auf
Servern praktisch finde.
Da klont man sich vielleicht auch mal ein Git-Repo.
Oder möchte
ein paar Sachen in der Shell angezeigt bekommen.
Bei Ubuntu finde ich den hier ganz gut.
Liquid
Prompt.
So gedönst hast du halt dann bei Ubuntu
dabei. Finde ich ganz schick.
Der zeigt dir dann auch die Temperatur
an von deinem System. Der zeigt
dir an, falls du doch mal eine Git-Repo auscheckst,
in welchem Brand du bist und sowas.
Ist einfach schön, dass das standardmäßig in den
Windows drin ist. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob in CentOS
nicht vielleicht auch drin ist. Aber CentOS ist halt
sehr klassisch, was die mitliefern, ja.
Mir gefällt Upt besser
als Yam oder DNF
oder was auch immer
die jetzt mittlerweile noch haben.
Upt finde ich ist
neben dem
von Archlinux das bequemste
und
das angenehmste.
Ähm
Ubuntu hat auch ein paar Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen.
Bist du denn, Sibaro? Wie diese
NetConfig, äh
NetPlan-Geschichte, YAML-Dateien für Netzwerk-Config,
sowas bescheuertes.
Ähm, sie haben kein
ASCII-Quarium dabei.
Das ist natürlich schon mal...
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Aber dafür, wie gesagt,
dafür haben sie
das Hackertool schlechthin dabei. Wichtig.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent.
Ist SL drauf wahrscheinlich, ja.
Leute, ich geb alles!
Ähm, da fällt mir ne Geschichte ein,
die, äh, wo uns
mal unser Ober-
Oberchef besucht hat.
Auf der Arbeit. Es ist ja so,
ähm, dass
wir, äh,
es gibt ja schon mehrere Geschichten, ja, und da
und der, der Ober-Ober-Typ
ist nicht der IT-Vorstandsmann,
sondern der,
der Ober-Ober...
Vorstands-, noch
Vor-Vorstandsmann, ja.
Und der war mal unterwegs
und wollte, wollte
irgendwas,
irgendwelchen Außendienst-Mitarbeitern, genau,
irgendwelchen Außendienst-Mitarbeitern
wollte der unsere, äh,
unser, unser, äh, unsere IT-Profis
wollte der zeigen, ja, wie, wie, wie geil,
wie geil die IT in der Bank
ist. Und
natürlich kommt der nicht einfach vorbei
und bringt irgendwie 20, äh,
Außendienstleute mit.
Also quasi Leute, die was verkaufen. Der hat ja jetzt auch nicht
irgendwelche random Außendienstleute mitgebracht, sondern
halt, wahrscheinlich war das ein Bonus
für die, die besonders viel verdient haben,
so nach dem Motto, hier bezahlen wir
Grund-, Grundgang in der Zentrale oder so.
Und, ähm,
natürlich hat er sich vorher angekündigt,
weil so un-,
ganz unvorbereitet geht das nicht.
Und,
ähm,
wobei, ne, das sind, das sind,
das sind zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten. Ähm,
das, äh, das andere muss ich
aber danach auch noch erzählen. Zumindest hat er sich
angekündigt, und da haben wir schon extra geguckt,
dass in dem einen Raum, das ist, äh,
quasi in, in, in, wir haben
nen extra Großraumbüro, wo
unsere Leute, sie, sitzen, die 24-7
Monitoring machen. Da hängt ne große Monitorwand
und so. Das ist halt der Raum, der am meisten
hermacht. Ähm,
und da haben sie ihn da halt rumgeführt.
Zumindest haben wir uns alle
dann darüber gesetzt, dass es da halt schön
beschäftigt aussieht, dass da viel los ist.
Und da haben wir uns im Vorfeld schon überlegt
und da haben auch unsere Chefs gesagt, ja,
es wär schön, wenn wir ein bisschen,
wenn wir ein bisschen beschäftigt tun könnten.
Und da haben wir uns halt hingesetzt
und überlegt, okay, was machen wir?
Und da haben
wir uns dann drauf geeinigt, okay, äh,
ein paar Leute setzen sich halt nebeneinander
und gucken dann bei mir, weil's anderen auf den
Bildschirm interessiert und der andere
macht halt irgendwas.
Und dann haben wir halt überlegt, ja, fuck, was machen wir
denn jetzt an? Und da haben wir dann halt
sowas hier gemacht.
Haben wir dann hier, Moment, ich brauch noch einen T-Max.
Äh, da haben wir dann, hab ich halt
sowas hier angemacht.
Äh, was weiß ich, was ich noch laufen,
ich glaub ein D-Stat hatt ich noch laufen und, und
irgendwie andoch
Zeug hatt ich dann laufen auf jeden Fall, ne.
Sah halt übelst, übelst
Hacker-Style aus. Und
mein, mein Sitznachbar hat irgendwie
35 Cluster, also
35 SSH-Fenster aufgehabt.
Sah halt übelst Hacker, Hackermäßig aus.
Da ging's voll ab. Hat gedacht, wundere
was hier grade, was hier grade
entsprechendes, äh, geforscht wird anscheinend.
Da kamen sie halt rein, haben sich umgeguckt
und sind dann auch mal zu den einzelnen Leuten
gegangen, so ein bisschen Smalltalk, blablabla, haha
und wie toll wir sind.
Und dann guckt er so bei meinem
Kollege neben auf dem Bildschirm und sagt so, ach,
davon versteh ich ja gar nix.
Da, weil er bei seinen 35 SSH-Fenster
aufhatte. Ich hatte halt nen Webbrowser
auf, da guckt er bei mir so auf dem Bildschirm und
meint, ah ja, damit kenn ich mich aus.
Da hab ich halt nur so gesagt, na, Moment.
Hab ich umgeschaltet hier drauf.
Und da hat er gesagt, oh je, oh je, ich, äh,
irgendwie hat er irgendeinen blöden Witz
gemacht, so. Und
da hab ich drauf
gesagt, damals, ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie's
genau gewesen ist. Der hat irgendwas
gesagt, da hab ich gesagt, oh, da hab ich keine Ahnung von.
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, wir haben das jetzt ja auch
grade extra aufgemacht, weil
wir gehört haben, sie kommen vorbei.
Und da hat er gesagt, hahaha
hab ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn du
wüsstest,
dass das jetzt einfach die Wahrheit
war, die ich dir erzählt hab,
hahaha
hat er nicht geglaubt.
Er sagt,
ja, ich hab, wir haben das jetzt ja auch extra aufgemacht,
weil sie, weil sie kommen.
Und da hat er so richtig so sein, haha,
guter Witz, Lache gemacht.
Und danach haben wir uns angeguckt und haben gesagt,
eigentlich haben wir nur erzählt, wie's war.
Aber ich glaube, der Typ ist nicht
blöd. Ich glaube,
der weiß das schon.
Richtig, ja. Das ist
Meta-G-Bait. Das ist Meta-G-Bait.
Das ist quasi G-G-Baited,
obwohl der andere denkt, es ist nicht
G-Baited und es
ist dann wirklich nicht G-Baited, weil's echt ist.
Das ist also wirklich schon
Next Level.
So, und da gibt's noch, da gibt's noch eine andere Sache, die kann ich
jetzt auch noch mal kurz zum Besten geben, weil ich muss ja, wie gesagt,
ich muss ja demnächst dann gleich weg.
Ähm,
wir machen mal Hacker-Hacker-Tools an
hier.
Ähm, eine Geschichte kann ich auch noch
mal zum Besten geben.
Wir haben einen Werbefilm
gedreht. Oder besser gesagt,
es, äh,
wir, äh,
eine Werbefirma hatte den Auftrag,
über unsere, über
die IT in unserer Zentrale einen Werbefilm
zu drehen. So rum.
Und
die sind dann angerückt und wir saßen halt
alle da. Wir haben uns natürlich mal wieder ein bisschen,
bisschen mehr Leute dahingesetzt, als
wir normalerweise sitzen.
Und das hat den nicht
gefallen. Das waren
halt nur
Männer,
weiße Männer,
im Alter
von
20 bis
40.
Und das war nicht, ähm,
nicht divers genug für den Film.
Deswegen
wurde dann gefaked, was
das Zeug hält, Alter.
Da haben Leute gesessen später
in dem Video, in diesem Büro. Die wussten
nicht mal, wo der Raum ist zu dem damaligen
Zeitpunkt. Wir hatten dann
im Endeffekt drei Mädels da sitzen.
Drei Mädels noch da sitzen.
Nen, nen, nen alten
Typ mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der war
wahrscheinlich in der Rente oder so, mit, mit
grauen Haaren und alles.
Eine mit Kopftuch.
Ähm, nen schwarzen.
Wir hatten alles. Wir waren ohne
Scheiß, wir waren die, die, in diesem Video
waren wir die diverseste Abteilung
auf diesem Planeten.
Also,
besser, besser als jeder,
jedes Microsoft Werbematerial.
Es war, es war wirklich, es war,
es war alles bei.
Wir hatten sogar Leute mit Tätowierungen dabei. Alles.
Alles.
Das war so krass divers,
dass der Film,
das war wahrscheinlich der,
der stylischste,
ähm,
Hipster und, und
NG Film aller
Zeiten.
Menschen hatten wir nicht drinnen, ne?
Und was ich halt witzig fand, ne?
Dass die dann wirklich Leute,
was halt witzig war, wer dann da gesessen hat,
ne? Es ist ja nicht so, dass da irgendwie
IT-Leute da gesessen hätten.
Da saß dann einer von der QS,
also von der Qualitätssicherung.
Es saß, ähm,
von,
vom Marketing saß eine da.
Dann
irgendeine, ähm,
Personalabteilungsfrau,
das war die mit dem Kopftuch.
Ähm, dann saß von,
ich glaube von der
Haustechnik saß einer da.
Darf man eigentlich noch, darf, darf
man Schwarzer sagen?
People, People
of Color heißt es ja jetzt.
Äh, der war von der Haustechnik.
Ähm, also in dem
gesamten, in dem gesamten Video über die,
über die, über unsere
IT-Abteilung saßen in dem Video
vielleicht 2 Leute
von 12,
13 da, die wirklich
aus der IT-Abteilung kamen.
Das war wirklich so zusammengefakt,
wie ich es noch nie gesehen habe, äh.
Ich fand, der Film ist aber gut.
Ich kann Ihnen das nicht zeigen, weil dann wüsste man,
wo ich arbeite, aber, äh, der Film war nicht
schlecht am Ende. Also die haben ihr Handwerk
verstanden. Ja, und um jetzt
mal die, den Bogen zurück
zu Ubuntu zu spannen, passt da jetzt witzigerweise
auch dazu.
Teile des Films wurden in Südafrika
aufgenommen.
Ich weiß, es hört sich jetzt an, als hätte ich mir das
ausgedacht, um eine gute Überleitung zu Ubuntu
zu haben, aber das stimmt.
Teile des Films wurden in Südafrika
aufgenommen. Nicht, weil irgendwie
äh, Südafrika tolle Schauplätze
hätte für, für das Video, was so IT-mäßig
aussieht, sondern,
weil Südafrika wohl
besonders, ähm, besonders
gutes, äh, Lichtverhältnisse
hat für,
frag mich, Dinger.
Nein, keine Waisenkinder gezeigt.
Die haben da, die haben, die haben dort
in irgendwelchen Büros Dinger aufgenommen,
weil irgendwie das Licht in Südafrika
besonders toll ist.
Und haben dann halt so getan, als wäre es hier.
Obwohl es in
Südafrika war. Ja.
Aber da sieht man
wieder den Unterschied zwischen
Realität
und was sich gut verkauft
und, und
sag mal, zumindest von dem, wo man halt
von denkt, es verkauft sich gut
und macht sich gut, ja. Und die
Realität ist nicht immer das, was, äh, was
gut aussieht.
Wir leben in einer Zeit, wo es halt
hip ist, divers zu sein.
Es ist da auch überhaupt
nichts dagegen zu sagen, aber es ist halt in dem
Fall bei uns nicht die Wahrheit gewesen.
Unser Team ist halt nur wirklich
nicht so
extrem divers, wenn man so will.
Da ist nicht, sind, da sind halt zu
90 Prozent 20
bis 45-jährige
weiße Männer. Es gibt aber
immer Mädels in der IT, muss man sagen.
Also es hat die letzten
Jahre schon zugenommen,
aber vom Verhältnis her ist es immer noch
so, dass es halt
auch, auch bei unseren Azubis, ja,
80 Prozent Typen,
die anfangen.
Also es scheint schon was dran zu sein,
dass sich Männer einfach mehr
für Technik interessieren als Frauen.
Hat sich denn nach dem Video was besser verkauft?
Das war kein Video, wo es drum ging, dass wir
mehr verkaufen. Das war ein Video,
um uns quasi,
ähm,
Image-mäßig, also
auch nicht nach außen, denn ich glaube, das Video
gab es nie nach außen, sondern halt in
dieser, in dieser, äh,
Konzern und, und
Partnerstruktur, um uns
als besonders gut dastehen zu lassen.
Und das hat anscheinend auch gut funktioniert. Imagefilm, ja.
In deiner Physik-Klasse ist kein
einziges Mädchen. Wir hatten
eins, zwei, drei,
drei
hatten wir.
Wir hatten drei Stück.
Ich glaube, ich weiß sogar noch, wie die heißen.
Aber
wir hatten eine Stefanie, wir hatten eine Jasmin
und wir hatten,
äh,
okay, wie die dritte
heißt, keine Ahnung. Wie die dritte
hieß, weiß ich nicht mehr. Aber wir
hatten drei Mädels in der Klasse.
Und das ist schon
zehn Jahre,
13 Jahre her.
Wann war denn deine Ausbildung? Nee, 2007.
Deswegen sage ich ja 13 Jahre
her.
Ja, also es gibt immer mehr,
aber
anteilmäßig gibt es halt nach wie vor
mehr Männer. Was ich
persönlich, da muss man ja aufpassen,
was man sagt, das ist ja schon schlimm, aber man muss,
ist halt mittlerweile so leider, dass man da aufpassen muss,
ähm, ich finde das
persönlich auch gar nicht schlimm.
Ich bin voll dafür,
dass jeder das machen soll,
was er sich wünscht
und was er irgendwie gebacken kriegt,
was er machen will, dass man ihm
die Chance gibt, da bin ich vollkommen dafür.
Weil wirklich jeder die Chance bekommt,
das zu machen, wo er irgendwie
drinnen aufgeht, ja.
Aber wenn sich nun mal
80% Männer für technische
Berufe entscheiden und nur 20% Frauen,
ey, da muss man damit leben.
Man kann ja schlecht die Mädels dazu
zwingen. Man kann ja schlecht
die Mädels dazu zwingen,
technische Berufe mehr zu ergreifen,
auf der Baustelle
zu arbeiten und sonst was zu machen.
Genauso wenig, wie man
Kerle dazu zwingen kann,
ähm, jetzt übermäßig,
keine Ahnung, Krankenpfleger,
Kindergärtner oder
sind da noch, was sind da noch so
die klassischen Frauenberufe, wo das denen
das so anhaftet. Ähm, und sowas
in der Richtung zu werden, muss ja nicht sein.
Es soll einfach schlicht und
ergreifend jedem das ermöglicht
werden und da sollte jeder die Chance
haben, ähm,
das zu machen, was er machen will.
Aber irgendwelche künstlichen,
ähm,
wie heißt, ähm,
Quoten und sowas, glaube ich nicht, dass das
zielführend ist.
Zahnarzthelferin Müllmann, ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das, dass das
zielführend ist, irgendwelche Quoten da einzuführen.
Weil im Endeffekt, wo, wo,
worauf läuft's denn raus?
Wenn man wirklich
verpflichtende Quoten einführt,
also sprich, wenn man quasi
gar keinen Pool an geeigneten
Bewerbern hat, aber man trotzdem
Leute
einstellen muss,
weil es die Quote vorschreibt,
dann führt das doch eigentlich eher dazu, dass
die ganze Sache noch unfairer wird.
Weil auf der einen Seite
muss ich dort, wo es
genug Leute gibt, müssen sich die Leute abrackern
und wirklich anstrengen,
um auf Position,
Stelle, was auch immer, xy
zu kommen. Und auf der anderen Seite,
wenn es, wo es zu wenige gibt,
kann man auch einfach
nur, weil man
da ist, dann dahin
kommen. Das ist doch auch nicht fair.
Deswegen bin ich kein Fan von, von
irgendwelchen Quoten.
Aber ich bin dafür,
dass man jedem ermöglichen sollte, das zu machen,
was er machen will. Und ich find's gut,
dass es immer mal Mädels gibt, die in technische
Berufe gehen. Das ist super. Man sollte
das denen auch durchaus schmackhaft machen, warum nicht.
Aber irgendwelche Quoten schaffen,
find ich bescheuert.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das
in manchen Bereichen schon solche
Ausprägungen
leider annimmt.
Ist auch eine Sache,
wenn wir auf dem Thema gar nicht zu sehr rumreiten,
da hab ich mich aber auch schon öfters drüber aufgelassen,
dass wir aktuell ein bisschen
viel, ähm,
oder, wie sag ich denn,
dass wir versuchen,
also, dass man das extrem
vermeidet,
irgendwo anzuecken.
Also mal angenommen,
ich hab jetzt, keine Ahnung,
mir fällt jetzt irgendwas Blödes ein,
ich poste das auf Twitter, ja, und ich hab
mir da jetzt nicht erst zwei Tage drüber
Gedanken gemacht, dann kann ich sicher sein,
dass das irgendjemand
anpisst.
Und, ähm, wenn ich groß genug
bin auf Twitter, also richtig
groß bin, dann kann auch
ein unüberlegter Twitter-Post zu einem
übelsten Shitstorm führen. Ja, manche Sachen
sind wirklich dämlich, die gepostet werden.
Bei manchen Sachen ist es auch vollkommen
gerechtfertigt, sich da wahnsinnig drüber aufzuregen.
Ähm,
aber muss man manchmal ein bisschen die Verhältnismäßigkeit
sehen.
Ich hab letztens auf Twitter einen Post gesehen,
da hat einer zum Blutspenden
aufgerufen.
Da denkt man sich doch jetzt
eigentlich, da kann ja nichts
Schlimmes dabei sein.
Da denkt man sich,
ey, was kann da ganz Schlimmes dabei
sein, wenn einer zu eigentlich einer guten Sache
zum Blutspenden aufruft.
Da kann doch, kann man sich doch gar nicht
dran stören. Doch kann man sich
dran stören, weil,
ähm, nee, nicht wegen Corona,
das ist schon ein bisschen, das war noch nicht
Corona, das ist schon, ist schon
wie sie, keine Ahnung, vier, fünf Wochen
her. Also da war Corona auch nicht so angesagt.
Und da haben sie sich
wirklich drüber aufgeregt,
weil der ein Bild gepostet
hat, wo man ein,
ein, ein, einen Arm gesehen
hat von jemand, der gerade Blutspenden war,
in dem so eine Abzapf,
Abzapfspritze
äh, gesteckt hat.
Und da hat da wirklich jemand
drauf geschrieben, ähm,
er findet es irgendwie unveran-
unverantwortlich, allein schon der, er findet es
irgendwie unverantwortlich, dass man hier
einfach, ähm, ähm,
quasi Leute
triggert mit spritzen Bildern.
Es gibt doch Menschen, die haben,
äh, panische Angst vor
Nadeln.
Alter, auf was sollst du denn noch
alles achten?
Auf was sollst du denn noch alles achten,
dass nicht, du kannst
es doch gar nicht mehr vermeiden, dass sich
irgendjemand angepisst ist.
Ich mein, es geht ums Blutspenden.
Was meint der denn?
Wie man das Blut aus dem Arm rauskriegt.
Durch, durch saugen.
Also, da passt eine
Spritze eigentlich thematisch ziemlich
gut dazu, ja.
Und da haben sie sich drüber
ereifert
und aufgeregt,
dass sie eine Spritze gepostet haben.
Und mit einem Messer, ja, super Idee.
Wenn du den Typ danach noch
zu was gebrauchen willst am Blutspenden ist
ein Messer, glaub ich, keine so gute Idee.
Ähm, da haben sie sich
ereifert und aufgeregt auf Twitter,
ernsthaft, dass die beim Tweet
über Blutspenden eine Spritze gepostet haben.
Und da war mir wieder klar,
ähm,
es, das,
ich vergesse es manchmal wieder, eigentlich ist mir das ja klar,
dass das heute echt
nicht mehr normal ist.
Oder das, was heute normal ist,
irgendwie nicht bei mir in den Kopf reingeht, sagen wir mal so.
Ich finde es okay,
wenn man, wenn man,
also ich finde es sogar gut,
wenn man ein bisschen feinfühlig vorgeht,
und nicht unbedingt absichtlich
Leute
anpisst, einfach nur
um Leute anzupissen.
Ja, das, da sag ich, das ist,
das ist sogar gut.
Man muss nicht unbedingt
notgedrungen Leute aufregen,
den ganzen Tag, ja, man gibt genug Troll-Accounts.
Aber man kann nicht,
es ist unmöglich heute,
alles zu umschiffen,
wo sich irgendjemand
angesprochen fühlen könnte.
Das ist, es ist mit,
das ist unglaublich mittlerweile in der Richtung.
Und vor allem,
was ich ja schlimm, was ich, was ich unterm Strich
daran eigentlich schlimm finde,
gar nicht mal so sehr,
die Leute sind mir da eigentlich wurscht.
Die denken einfach, manchen Leuten kann man nicht,
manchen Leuten kann man nicht helfen.
Eine Sache, die ich persönlich, gerade als jemand,
der technisch interessiert ist,
und der, der sich eher für technische Zusammenhänge
interessiert, was ich, was ich persönlich
blöd finde, ist,
dass dadurch an vielen Stellen
reine,
ähm,
wie soll man sagen, reine,
reine Gefühlslagen
vor
Inhalt geht.
Ich glaube, das trifft's, das trifft's
eigentlich ganz gut.
Also sprich, dass es wichtiger ist,
dass man eventuell
den einen von tausend
vermeidet, den es anpissen könnte,
und dann lieber gar nichts zuschreibt,
oder
die Sachen so schwammig
und ausgedünnt, dass keiner mal was mit
anfangen kann.
Und das muss eigentlich nicht sein.
Ich denke, man kann durchaus mitleben,
wenn man
eine Meinung zu einem Thema hat,
dass man damit den ein oder anderen
vielleicht
findet, der die nicht gut findet.
Das,
damit müsste doch, müsste man doch eigentlich,
also damit müssten doch alle klarkommen eigentlich.
Derjenige, der es sagt,
derjenige, der halt nicht damit einverstanden ist.
Naja.
Gut, aber das ist ja heute nicht so.
Ähm,
bei deinem Post zum Thema Klopapier gab es
auch ein paar Leute, die entweder am Trollen oder
waren oder die hatten andere Probleme. Ey,
mein Klopapierpost,
da habe ich ja gegen das verstoßen,
was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Ich habe diesen Post nur gemacht, um Leute zu ärgern.
Weil ich gerade gesagt habe,
man muss ja nicht unbedingt Post machen, um Leute zu ärgern.
Aber, mein Klopapierpost
habe ich nur gemacht, um Leute zu ärgern.
Man beachtet,
erstens ist es der 1. April,
aber es war kein April-Scherz, muss ich gleich
dazu sagen.
Mein Klopapierpost habe ich einzig und allein gemacht,
um Leute zu triggern.
Allerdings hat es
einen wahren Kern,
denn ich bin der,
wie sagt man in der Politik so schön,
ich bin der festen, es ist dreilagig,
der festen Überzeugung,
dass so, wie ich das
gemanagt habe mit dem Einkauf vom
Klopapier, es für alle Beteiligten das Beste ist.
Ich habe den Kram
im Internet bestellt vor 14 Tagen.
Das heißt, ich habe
14 Tage lang niemand
im Supermarkt Klopapier weggekauft.
In Zeiten,
wo es eh schon zu wenig im Supermarkt gibt.
Ich bin nicht
in einen Supermarkt gegangen, um
mir Klopapier
zu kaufen, in einer Zeit,
wo man Kontakt zu anderen Menschen vermeiden
soll. Also schon mal 2
große Pluspunkte.
Dazu kommt, dass es logistisch einfacher
ist, wenn man das im Internet
bestellt und
einen gewissen Vorlauf
hat. Also da wird
nichts irgendwie
überladen oder sonst
was. Da wird halt einfach verschickt, wenn es da ist.
Vergewaltigung trendet in
Germany. Da will ich jetzt gar nicht draufklicken.
Monka Toss.
Also ich bin
der Ansicht, die Art
und Weise, wie ich den Kram bestellt habe
und gemanagt habe,
war für alle Beteiligten
das Beste. Es gibt aber genug Leute,
die das nicht einsehen wollen. Hier riesig viele Diskussionen
darunter, wie asozial
ich bin und es waren konnte, mir
Klopapier zu bestellen. Also ich muss sagen,
wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt seit
Anfang Corona in keinem Supermarkt
vor Ort Klopapier gekauft.
Ich hatte ein bisschen Vorrat, aber
irgendwann ist der auch mal weg.
So und ich habe jetzt so viel gekauft,
dass ich einfach auch
ohne jemand im Supermarkt das wegzukaufen
wohlgemerkt habe. Ich meine, es gibt ja genug Klopapier.
Es gibt halt vor Ort kein Klopapier.
Sodass ich auch
die nächsten fünf Monate,
vier, fünf Monate
niemand im Supermarkt den Kram
wegkaufen muss.
Ich finde, das ist vom Ansatz her
das Richtige. Und was mich viel mehr
schockiert hat bei diesem Thema ist,
wie unfähig die meisten Leute
sind, überhaupt
zu verstehen,
dass die Möglichkeit besteht,
im Internet Klopapier zu kaufen.
Die haben das nicht gecheckt.
Dann haben dann Leute gesagt,
ja, du hast
dafür gesorgt, dass es bei mir im Rewe
nichts gibt. Da habe ich ihm erklärt, warum
das nicht der Fall ist. Dass ich sogar
er, der kam auch noch aus Frankfurt,
dass ich sogar damit dafür gesorgt habe,
dass die Chance, dass er Klopapier bekommt,
höher ist im Rewe als
niedriger.
Weil ich ihm nie was weggekauft habe.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau.
Das war der eine, der sich darüber aufgeregt hat,
dass er im Rewe nichts mehr gekriegt hat.
Und dann gab es andere,
die konnten es nicht nachvollziehen,
wie man, ja, natürlich ist es
viel, aber das heißt, wenn man einen Großhändler bestellt,
von dieser Sorte gab es halt nur 96
Rollen.
Und die anderen
haben teilweise gar nicht verstanden, wie das möglich ist.
Der nächste kam an, hier unten,
und hat geschrieben,
ich habe bei Amazon geguckt
und bei Amazon gibt es nichts mehr.
Was heißt hier online bestellen?
Alter, es gibt nicht nur Amazon.
Schmeiß halt mal Google an,
DuckDuckGo oder irgendeine
Suchmaschine und such nach
Klopapier kaufen.
Das war für die Leute komplett Neuland.
Die haben es nicht kapiert.
Wo ich mir denke, okay, das ist Twitter,
das heißt, auf Twitter sind eigentlich die
etwas technikaffineren, also
nicht die ganzen Kack-Noobs.
Die haben es nicht kapiert.
Das hat
mich echt wieder schockiert, ja.
Da ist es zwar.
Viele können leider selbst nicht googlen.
Das ist so, ja.
Das ist leider so.
Guck mal, wir haben null Drop Frames.
Heute ist Vodafone nicht so, sondern
heute ist Vodafone so.
Wieso stacken alle Klopapier?
Ganz ehrlich, was hat das für einen Sinn?
Gar keinen.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn,
dass man sich so viel Klopapier lagert,
daheim.
Rein nüchtern betrachtet.
Das Problem, was jetzt halt gerade existiert,
ist,
du kriegst vor Ort nichts mehr.
Doch, doch.
Zwei Jahre hält das garantiert nicht.
Für zwei Leute.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Du hast das Problem,
dass du vor Ort nichts mehr kriegst gerade
und im Falle der Fälle,
wenn du keinen großartigen Vorrat hattest
und mein Vorrat ist jetzt auch mal fertig,
nach irgendwie,
ich hatte noch ein paar Packungen da
und alle gewesen
und du kriegst vor Ort nichts mehr.
Vor Ort kriegst du aktuell nur noch eine Packung.
Das heißt, du kommst damit gar nicht hin.
Weil du brauchst einen gewissen Vorrat.
Stell dir vor, du wirst jetzt wirklich mal krank.
Stell dir vor, du kriegst wirklich Corona
und liegst zwei Wochen, drei Wochen daheim.
Und du hast nichts,
du kannst nicht scheißen gehen,
weil du kein Klopapier hast.
Also die einzige Möglichkeit,
die es geben würde, wäre,
wenn die Leute nicht so bescheuert wären
und den Supermarkt leer kaufen würden
und jeder könnte sich einfach
im Supermarkt normalen Tagesbedarf holen.
Oder normalen Tagesbedarf
plus Vorrat.
Das wäre für alle Beteiligten das Beste.
Also man könnte einfach
in den Supermarkt
und sich
vier Packungen holen
und dann hat man erstmal genug.
Das wäre für alle Beteiligten das Beste.
Ist es aber nicht.
Hast du nicht sowieso
dein japanisches Klo?
Das ist aber kein japanisches Klo.
Das ist ein Geberit Aqua Clean
8500 Plus.
Oder?
Oder? 8000 Plus.
Nicht 8500 Plus.
Excellent.
8500 Plus.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Leute, es ist 22.25 Uhr.
So langsam aber sicher muss ich mal ins Bett.
Ich bin müde.
Resident Sleeper.
Oh, der Hacker.
Denkst du, läuft der immer noch?
Äh.
Möchte sich das nicht beenden vielleicht?
Was ist da los?
Monka Smoke.
Wo habe ich denn mein Smoke?
Mein Smoke Emote.
Ah, jetzt.
Weiß gar nicht,
warum ich das suspendet habe.
Ja, der andere kann das suspenden.
Dein Klo hat Raytracing.
RTX on Klo.
Ja, das muss sein.
Kann man 2020 schon mal haben.
Also, Nudelvorräte habe ich tatsächlich genug.
Ich habe es ja schon mal erzählt,
ich habe einen Schrank,
oder fast einen Schrank voller Nudel.
Den habe ich aber immer.
Weder aus irgendwelchen Corona-Gründen,
noch irgendwie, weil ich der Hardcore-Prapper bin oder so,
sondern weil der Kram hält.
Dann reicht es,
wenn man einmal ordentlich einkauft
und dann hat man erstmal Nudel.
Eats.
So Leute, Fazit für heute.
Wie war der Sound?
Besser? Schlechter?
Kein Unterschied gehört?
Besser, gut.
Lull, jetzt geht der Chat.
Ich raste aus.
OMG, der Chat geht.
Ungewöhnlich nice, okay.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen,
lasse ich das doch mal so mit den Audio-Settings.
Du klingst älter als sonst.
Naja,
vielleicht bin ich jetzt ja auch älter als sonst.
Ihr wisst doch nicht, wann ich Geburtstag habe.
Warum kein ZFS mehr
auf der Arbeit?
Weil wir keinen Anwendungszweck
mehr so wirklich für haben.
Das einzige, wo wir riesengroßes
also, was ist riesengroß?
Das einzige, wo wir richtig viel Storage am Stück haben,
ist für die Oracle-Datenbank-Zeug.
Aber ansonsten haben wir wenig
große Storage-Sachen.
Wir haben da keinen Anwendungszweck
für.
Vielleicht für unsere
Mail-Backups, da wäre das noch eine
Option.
Aber das funktioniert anders.
Ja, deswegen haben wir keinen ZFS
auf der Arbeit.
Wir haben da irgendwie nicht den Anwendungszweck
für.
Und was man auch dazu sagen muss,
wir haben keine wahnsinnig
guten ZFS-Pros.
Ich meine, ich kenne mich
so die grundlegenden Admin-Sachen
kenne ich mich mit ZFS aus.
Aber ich würde sagen,
ich bin weit davon entfernt, irgendwie wahnsinnig gut
mit ZFS auszukennen.
Äh, ZFS
und Performance nicht zwangsläufig.
Nee.
ZFS ist nicht
unbedingt schneller als ein normales
Dateisystem.
Ich würde sogar sagen, durch das alles, was drum herum passiert,
ist sogar rein I.O. technisch
und also
Zugriffszeiten technisch und
I.O. auf dem Plan würde ich sogar sagen,
ist ZFS ein Ticken
langsamer sogar als
andere Dateisysteme. Dafür hast du halt
die ganzen Vorteile von ZFS.
Was ZFS halt sehr schnell macht, ist,
dass es erstmal die Sachen in RAM packt
und dass man eventuell noch
SSD-Caches verwenden kann.
Aber wenn man das mal
außen vor lässt, würde ich sogar sagen,
durch den ganzen Kram, den ZFS zusätzlich
macht, ist ZFS sogar
einen Ticken schneller als
so, äh, einen Ticken langsamer als
so ein normales File-System.
ClusterFS? Nee, haben wir auch nicht.
Wir haben Ceph, haben wir.
CephFS.
CephFS. Und das tut
wunderbar. Es ist jetzt aber nicht so
das Performance-Wunder, aber es ist groß.
So.
Leute, mal gucken, ob wir uns morgen sehen. Spätestens
Sonntag sehen wir uns. Ähm,
ja, schlaf gut. Wir sehen uns.
Bis spätestens Sonntag.
Macht's gut.
C U